Yes,
it's true that the new Joe Rogan
experience studio will have a desk that
has meow written into it in metal.
Damn.
That's how we roll bitches real deep and
we hire craftsman having shit
constructed right now.
Made out of old re a reused farm.
Would the Joe Rogan experience podcast
is brought to you by many,
many things,
ladies and gentlemen,
because the shit all costs money and I'm
trying to get paid.
You know what I'm saying?
One of the things were brought by is a
fucking bad ass new cell phone company
called Ting.
Ting is it's.
They use the sprint network so it's not
like they have three towers in the whole
country now.
They have a fucking major network.
They use a sprint network and they make
shit really simple.
They cut out all the bs that is normally
involved in having a cell phone.
Like for instance,
you don't have to have a contract,
you don't have to pay if you cancel,
like there's weird shit that happens
when you get a cell phone.
It's weird.
It's not like buying gas.
You can't say,
well,
you,
I don't want to use your gas anymore so
I'm not going to give you any more
money.
No,
you,
you somehow or another got roped into
some weird thing where you've got to
continue to give them money and if you
don't want to give them money anymore,
you've got to give them extra money.
Three hundred and $50.
He usually kind of bullshit is that.
That's nonsense.
That should be illegal and what team
does is they take it upon themselves to
try to create a moral business,
a business that that's fair.
A business that makes sense.
No contracts,
no bundling and ride along services,
no overage charge.
If you use a certain amount of cell
phone minutes per month and you don't
use like all of your minutes,
they roll over into the next month the
way it should be.
Rogan.ting.com.
That's where you want to go and you'll
save 50 bucks off of any smartphone and
they have some dope phones,
especially the one that I got from them
is the Samsung Galaxy s three and it is
fucking bad ass.
I love it.
Especially for looking at pictures and
looking at websites.
It's enormous,
man.
The screen is gorgeous.
Is it better than the iphone?
It's not better.
It's different.
It's bigger screen.
It's a bigger screen.
I know that,
that part's better for sure.
But um,
I really am so used to the apple
operating system that it will be hard
for me to say what's better and what's
worse.
And by the way,
I kept a blackberry for a long time.
I hung in there,
dude.
I took body shop.
I saw people.
I saw Mike Young last night using a
blackberry,
probably reminding himself of the old
jokes that he's got written out.
It's blackberry.
This,
uh,
sorry my tongue.
I hate to do that to you.
And Mike Young,
you know,
I love them.
Sort of.
I do love him.
He's a great guy.
He's a great human being.
I just give him.
I give everybody shit about their act.
You know,
if you're,
if you're telling the same jokes for 10
years,
someone should give you shit and you
should snap out of it.
I think that's for all of us.
Can you think Duncan?
Yes,
but other than that my comes and awesome
dude.
He's very funny too.
Very funny person.
What are you doing with that noise?
Getting crazy.
I like what you're doing with tripping
you out.
You aren't tripping me out.
I like that.
Setting the stage.
Um,
so go to [inaudible] dot [inaudible] dot
com and find out more.
Find out the technical shit that I can't
tell you and see all the different
phones that are available.
Lots of different android phones are
available and even like regular phones
leave if you're,
if you're crazy,
you're one of those nutty dudes likes
one of those flip Dana White's one of
those many dudes.
He's got like flip phone.
It's got a little flip phone.
That's how they all had them in Japan.
Remember in Japan they all had high tech
flipped.
Totally different though,
but still teaching as you say,
it's creating a situation where you
don't have to have a contract and they
have cheap phones.
They have great.
That's called prank central.
I can just pop in there and get a phone
for a month and then put that in my
friend's trunk or in a briefcase.
So they think they found some government
phone and then randomly call them
fuckers.
Fuck yes.
Who the fuck is wrong with you?
Why would you think to use it like that?
Especially in the middle of a fucking
commercial
that that helps sell the phones to cont
was what's wrong with praying?
Thank you for landing.
Now.
That's really fake.
Anyway,
back to the commercial.
Go to [inaudible] dot ting.com
and check out all that shit.
We're also brought to you by death squad
dot TV,
[inaudible] dot TV.
[inaudible] DOT TV is to the website of
Brian Red band.
Uh,
he was,
uh,
the first one to,
to put a website up that represents what
desk squad is,
is our little family of fuckheads.
That's us.
We're the desk squad.
Long story anyway.
It's,
um,
if you go to [inaudible] dot tv,
you can buy a desk,
want tee shirt and we see them at so
many of these,
uh,
these shows that we do and uh,
it's,
it's bad ass to say,
you know,
so many people wearing these silly
fucking shirts.
I'm a go to [inaudible] dot TV and you
can pick them up is also stickers for
sale and news of all upcoming tour
dates.
A lot of guys are starting to do a
little mini road trips.
I know Brian's got one coming up in
Columbus,
Ohio with.
Yeah,
with Brendan Walsh and Tony Hinchcliffe
and a special guest.
So I can't tell you about who's pretty
fucking bad ass.
So I'm going to Vancouver to not you
bitch.
It's not all about you
motherfucker.
It's not all about him.
I'm in the middle of a commercial for
Brian.
You like,
I'm going somewhere to Vancouver to you,
man.
Just calm down.
I didn't get the program.
No,
you should be happy though.
Somebody's got another desk squad
tattooed.
This makes it,
I think the 15th one and check this out.
It's the new cat.
The one that you like so much.
Oh Wow.
That's good.
That's a really good version of that is
fucking creepy as shit isn't it?
And I can't even tell what part of his
body because it looks like it's very
big.
It's clearly as.
It's weird.
I'm not a hardcore.
Porn is going on there.
You've got a lot of porcelain.
Nice.
Eat some vegetables.
I don't know what's happening.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible]
dot com.
That's o n n I t and [inaudible] Dot com
is a essentially a supplement company
all for high end athletics.
Supplements and what we call nootropics
and what nootropics are is
far more complicated for a retard like
myself to be describing and would really
seem hypocritical if I had some Alpha
brain with my beer.
Is it not good with beer?
I don't think.
Does it really freaked me out?
No,
I don't think it goes with beer.
Brian Duncan,
excuse me.
No,
I don't think it's a nutritional and
alcohol.
It's like the opposite of nutritional.
Alright dude.
Silly Bitch.
If you go to [inaudible] dot com,
o n n I,
t you can check out all the different
supplements that are available.
Um,
all of them are things that I have used
extensively before we ever got involved
in the company.
It's all stuff that I believe in.
Anything that I ever sell you on this
silly fucking show.
One thing I can guarantee you,
if I say something,
even if I'm incorrect,
I believe it.
Um,
I'll never tell you anything I don't
believe.
And if I find out that I'm wrong,
I'll tell you that.
And if I use something and I tell you to
use something,
it's because it's a really solid product
period.
That goes all the way back to the
fleshlight.
Ladies and gentlemen,
very underrated product.
Flashlight,
right Brian,
just because I encouraged you,
play a little piano in the background
doesn't mean you can have fucking aliens
landing on my head.
You're freaking me out,
man.
The newest things we have at a on it,
our hemp force,
which is this new delicious protein
powder,
it's the best tasting protein powder in
the world.
It's fucking fantastic.
It's made out of hemp,
which is hard to get an illegal in this
country.
Duncan trussell illegal.
I know they've.
Even though it doesn't even get you
high,
that's a good answer to the question
that inevitably comes to these poor
folks that have to get drug tested at
work.
No,
we don't.
None of them.
Like if you.
If you eat hemp protein powder,
you will not test positive for thc,
but if you eat poppy seed bagels,
you will test positive for heroin,
so you've got to be careful about that,
which is really crazy.
But it is true.
They tell you not to eat poppy seed
bagels before you go in for a drug test.
Does that mean that you could take
enough poppy seed bagels and extract
heroin out of them?
I do not know.
I don't think so.
I think it's just a confusion in your
system because I think the urine test
that they use just register metabolites
and it's just the same metabolite.
Apparently.
I got it.
I don't really understand it.
I don't think so.
I don't think you can get high from it.
I don't think you could just eat all
day.
I can't imagine if that's why the appeal
of bagels at poppy seeds.
We're just super mild heroin,
you know,
and you just eat it in the morning and
just feel everything feels so good.
How poppy seeds don't digest full laser.
Like when you're wiping emily's little
seeds flying all over your hands.
Yeah,
they're kind of tricky.
Well,
people had been arrested for having
those seeds on them when they go to a
like the Middle East and like really
strict drug countries because their
seeds of like set off alarms and those
fucking eight.
Remember those things that they use for
a little while that would push dust off
of you that they don't use those
anymore.
I just stopped using those because dudes
are going to jail for fucking poppy
seeds and other countries.
Fuck,
that's just my ex opposition anyway.
Have hemp force will not make you test
positive.
It's just the plant and it is a.
it's a.
it's not psychoactive at all.
Even though it's completely,
completely illegal.
Yet legal.
It's really weird.
It's totally legal to have.
It's totally legal to sell,
but you can't grow it here.
You have to grow somewhere else.
It's really a fucking.
It's,
it's,
it's clear corruption and it's clearly
the pharmaceutical drug companies
controlling agriculture and controlling
our access to one of the greatest plants
the world has ever known for whatever
fucking goofy ass reason our government
has let this go and place and even
though they know that this hemp plant,
even though it's related to marijuana,
it has no psychoactive properties.
You cannot get high from it,
but it has an amazing source of protein,
amazing source of amino acids.
You can make essential oil out of it.
You can make fuel out of it.
You can build houses with it.
It's really unbelievable.
That hampers illegal,
but it is so we have to buy it from
Canada,
but it's legal to have it.
Once you get it,
once you fucking let somebody else grow
it,
it's so crazy.
It's just one more giant piece of
evidence that we're fucked.
But if you go to [inaudible] dot com,
that's o n n I t,
you can get yourself some hemp force.
It's Yummy.
It's not.
It doesn't have,
it's got one gram of sugar per serving,
one I think.
Yeah,
something.
Whatever small amount is,
and it's all Stevia that it's sweetened
with,
so it's sweetened with natural
sweeteners and it's Yummy is fuck and
it's got Makkah and it's also got a raw
cocoa in it.
So go to [inaudible].
Com comments o n n I t.
all right,
you fucking get some battle ropes in
your system.
We've got kettle bells,
battle ropes,
do a lot of manly shit.
Duncan Trussell,
and if you use a code name Brogan,
you will save 10 percent off any an all
supplements.
All right,
freaks.
Duncan trussell's here.
Let's get the party role.
Yeah,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
All Day.
Powerful contrast.
A lot of times you know someone,
you can know someone for a long time and
you go,
wow,
this fucking weird cat,
man.
I ain't never met anybody like him and
you never get it.
You're like,
what is this dude is not like anybody
ever.
I wonder how this guy grew up and then
you go to the town where they grew up
and you go,
oh,
okay,
okay.
Okay.
I just got a huge piece of the Duncan
trussell puzzle this weekend in
Asheville,
North Carolina.
Asheville is so awesome.
I don't want to tell people about
Asheville because I'm scared they're
going to move there.
I know.
I'm scared.
They'll move there and fucked up place
up.
It's crazy.
I mean it's grown so fast,
already mad because it's.
It's unbelievably beautiful.
It's,
it's the whole thing is so ridiculous.
You've got this incredibly gorgeous
landscape all around you everywhere.
These intense green mountains and then
there's a super cool people in this town
where you can walk around everywhere and
you're like,
whoa.
I mean,
it's like,
it's like they took the best parts of
Austin and moved into the North
Carolina.
Right.
That's a perfect description.
It's like southern cool people,
but it's like freebasing Austin,
if that's possible.
It's really Canadian mining it.
Austin.
It's Austin in an inner needle.
Shoved right into your Dick,
but you didn't get to walk around
new shops I went to.
There's a tea room there were like,
like there's opium den with
blankets everywhere.
People wear their shoes.
Offsetting like reading poetry and it's
fucking cool places.
So weird.
It's weird.
It's awesome though.
It was awesome.
The show was awesome.
Hanging out with the people there.
It was awesome.
Thanks to my friend Sam for hooking me
up,
taking care of us out there.
It was a that the whole place was just
so strange.
It's like what a crazy little town.
It's so small.
It's so small and cool and like
everything.
I.
I just loved everything about it.
It's like occupy Wall Street turned into
a city now.
It's not because it's not as
complaining.
That's true,
but it is filled with.
I mean it is filled with subversive
folks.
It's,
there's a lot.
There's a lot of people there who are
apparently in the Environmental
Liberation Front.
Ecoterrorists perhaps are hanging out
there.
Oh my God.
You should probably not say that on the
air.
Doing the government's work.
I think people.
Oh yeah.
It'd be really hard to figure out.
There might be ecoterrorists there.
I saw none writing down the fucking
street on some giant tricycle
cases on the phone.
That wasn't a nun.
That was a chick who's going to go fuck
her boyfriend and he wanted her to come
over dress like a nun.
That's what that was.
That's a gross.
Yeah.
That's a great girlfriend.
That's.
That was.
It wasn't at my house on a tricycle
dressed as a nun.
I'm Horny,
but there were a few churches there,
so maybe it is,
you know,
I think religion that is.
I've never been to the one place that
has no religion,
like even a boulder.
Boulder's pretty,
pretty liberal,
intelligent,
you know,
sort of a left wing.
He kind of a place that had plenty of
churches.
My friend has sent me this thing.
I haven't listened to it yet on this
debate that they did as to whether or
not the world would be a better place if
religion did not exist and it's like a.
like these are professional debaters and
intellectuals.
I can't remember what it's like on NPR
or something,
but the end result was they decided to
have the world's better without religion
that they say that,
but yes and no.
I think religion serves as an operating
system for a lot of people and if
they didn't have religion you'd have to
explain shit to them and that could get
so tiresome.
They will get so tiresome to sit around
with some blundering Moron pontificating
on what it means to have a finite life
in an infinite universe.
And what,
what part of you know,
this part of this experience you really
do play,
what part do you play and what,
what is your consciousness all about and
why you so scared of it shutting off.
Know those are scary,
terrifying questions for the average
person and you know,
maybe like,
you know,
maybe some ditch digger do doesn't need
to know that.
Maybe there's some dudes who have some.
I believe there's people that have
brains that work way better than mine.
I've seen it.
I've talked to people that it's not just
a matter of education.
It's a matter of some people are gifted,
you know,
there's some people have a little tiny
hands and then there's people that are
built like Shaquille o'neal and he could
grab them and crush them and it's not
fair.
It doesn't make any sense,
but it's just the way it is.
And I think that there's some people
that are,
they're living in this life as humans,
but yet they're not quite human to like
just below human,
like you talked to them and you're like,
um.
So,
uh,
so what do you think happens when you
die?
Well,
man,
for sure you go to heaven and you get to
be with Jesus.
Well,
I've believed this and I was a child and
you're talking to them and you know,
there's like a weird disconnect with the
person.
Like they,
they talk and it's not,
not even that they're there,
they're not just like this.
I've met some really intelligent
Christians.
Don't get me wrong.
It's not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is there's certain
people that are just really dumb and
they really aren't capable of thinking
about deep shit.
They're not capable of pondering the
really insane question of what the fuck
this life is.
They're not capable of it.
So religion I've always felt was like a
nice scaffolding for people like that.
It lets them experience all the benefits
of,
of being a positive person and being a
giving and loving person.
You know,
we all experience those benefits,
you know,
it's just,
they're,
they're teaching them to do it in the,
the,
the way that it's,
it's transcribing the wishes of some
holy master who created you and I said
it once.
I'm not fucking saying it again.
Write it down.
This is what you do,
do it or else you go to hell.
It's like,
it's almost like it's structured to make
the idiots like have a really simple
moral path.
Like it gives you a nice little story to
explain the really weird but real
complexities of love and positive
thinking and,
and how it shapes lives and how your
intention shapes lives in your
imagination,
shapes your life and how this thing is
malleable and it's,
it's not understood.
This life that we're living simply not
understood.
That's too fucking weird for some
people,
they're not gonna they can handle that,
that's not getting in there,
that that's going to their ear and
bouncing off like it hit a fucking
trampoline.
So for some people,
religion allows them to be on a good
path.
It allows them to,
you know,
to do good and to experience the result
of that even though they're doing it
because of some fictional character,
it's like they're still doing the same.
They're doing the correct things.
So like when religion gets nutty when
you get into like the inquisition or
stabbing cartoon makers because they
drew your guy.
When religion goes completely off the
tracks like that,
that's when it becomes a problem.
But I think that's not the majority of
religious people.
I think the majority of religious people
probably benefit from it in a sense of
community for sure.
You know,
churches are a big part of neighborhoods
and communities,
you know,
it's a big part of how people interact
with each other.
And if you could find something that
was,
uh,
a religion where,
you know,
it made sense to you,
if it,
if it was a logical religion,
it actually would probably be a good
thing to be a part of because you're,
what you're doing is you're committing
your family and you're committing all
the families around you that are all in
the sort of community together to take
part in some sort of journey of
spiritual Islam.
Can I play devil's advocate literally?
Sure.
Against religion.
So,
um,
because I agree with you,
but I think that the problem is that it
creates a not only a structure where
people can sort of rest and have an
ethical system that they're not going to
come up with on their own.
But obviously the danger of all that is
that certain unscrupulous human beings
have figured out that if they put on the
right costume,
they can convince dopes to give them
cows suck their day,
take gold.
Because all they have to say is.
And they're like,
God,
they're the priests.
And religious leaders become like gods
agents,
like ca for God,
where they're like,
yes,
I'm taking the cause for God.
I'll tell you what God wants and it
wants you to blow me.
Conveniently in,
I don't know why,
because he's crazy,
but he wants you to suck my dick and he
wants seven of your cows.
I don't even know why likes cow
and he would like 10 percent of
everything you make for the rest of your
life.
That's what he said.
I just don't kill the Messenger.
We're not going to put it on paper.
I just want you to continue to pay that.
Yeah,
just that's not even on paper,
right?
When you tithe,
it's not like written somewhere or you
have to give 10 percent of your money.
Right?
Isn't that some people just do.
I don't know if there's a scriptural
thing that says 10 percent.
I think it's something that just sort of
seems like a logical number,
but I remember that it was a couple of
years ago in India and in a temple,
they like opened up at the faults in the
temple.
They hadn't opened it up or they found
some vaults and it was just filled with
gold,
just filled with fucking gold and you
know,
everyone around the temple was in offer
all this money.
But when you really think about what
that goal came from,
it came from hypnotized people who
believed that these priests were in some
way representing God.
And then the gold didn't even go
anywhere.
It molded in the basement of a fucking
temple.
Wow.
So it's so when,
when you see that there's that level of
exploitation that happens in like you,
you retweeted that amazing youtube video
of the guy whose job it is to suck the
freshly circumcised kids cock.
And he's explaining why according to
religion,
that's in my.
That's the guy in my act.
People think that that's fake.
That's the really is real.
I couldn't believe it do.
I did think you were exaggerating.
I couldn't believe that that's a,
uh,
an actual.
Yeah.
Well,
it's not only that he was justifying it.
He was justifying it by quoting the
pages.
It says in page 64 chapters.
He's going through all this nonsense
with his fucking wizard outfit on his
goofy ass beard and he's explaining
where it says it's okay to suck that
baby's Davies.
He's so.
He's so completely lost his objectivity
that he,
he is actually trying to explain why
this is necessary.
I think there's a distinction to make
between that deck,
that baby deck.
It's not just a baby's deck,
it's a bleeding,
babysit a screaming babies there can,
you know,
like I say in the bit about it that I do
in my act,
like how the fuck do we know that that
kid can't remember that we're just
assuming just because he can't talk and
he,
you know,
that he doesn't have a way to express
how much it sucks that you cut his dick
and start sucking on it.
But for sure you don't know whether or
not that baby can remember that.
That seems like a really traumatic
moment and I remember some intensely
traumatic moments from when I was young.
So I would think that would be something
that would fucking haunt the back of
your brain for the rest of your life.
Some old creepy asshole speaking in a
dead language and sucking your Dick
while he's wearing a wizard costume.
Bloody Day.
Your Dick that he just mutilated slash
Dick.
While your parents don't even save you,
your parents let this stupid.
Yeah,
they're paying dues to get this dummy to
fucking cut your bloody duck.
Suck it.
I just had my mom on my podcast and I
was like,
what did.
How did it go when I came out of your
pussy?
Did they circumcise me?
Right?
Then they cut it off then and she's
like,
yeah.
She said it was sometime around there.
She's like,
she's like,
but you didn't like it.
You cried.
Jesus Christ.
No Shit.
I cried.
You snipped off the tip of my car.
It's so crazy.
It's everybody's mutilated.
You know?
The majority of Americans are mutilated
and it's a weird thing with people where
they don't want to admit that this is
like,
it's really kind of people.
You're so exaggerating.
Rogan.
Fucking relax.
Mutilating.
That's a really what it is.
It's like skin is there to protect the
tip of your Dick.
Don't you think uncircumcised macaques
and porn look weird knowing don't Duncan
the skin is
supposed to protect the tip of your Dick
and your Dick is supposed to be like
glistening mucusy.
It's supposed to be like super
sensitive,
but instead they hacked that shit off
and the tip of your Dick Dries out.
It's not supposed to be dry like that.
It's supposed to be moist like inside a
woman's vagina.
That's what your Dick supposed to be
like and it's supposed to feel better
that way because of that,
because if it's moist and slippery and
then there's this nonsense that people
are pushing and it's all been disproven
by science about aids.
People are saying that it's like to
protect people from aids.
Like that is one of the craziest ideas I
have ever fucking heard.
Is that somehow or another extra for
skin?
Dick skin is gonna protect you.
If you fuck a guy got aids.
Like that is one of the craziest ideas
I've ever heard.
Like you're going gonna fuck that guy
man.
He's got aids.
Like dude,
I'm circumcised.
Oh well go,
go fuck away.
Go hit it buddy.
Like this.
Not Protecting you from AIDS,
there's no fucking way that protects you
from aids.
That's ridiculous,
but we we can justify doing it.
We want to justify that it was done to
us and we were in denial about it.
You're,
you're hacking off a piece of a little
kid's Dick and there's no science for it
whatsoever.
It's craziness and the majority of
people do it.
How many pounds of baby for skin meet?
It's generated a year enough to feed
like a couple dogs for life,
right?
Couple bears.
Thinking about all the babies being born
and just chop,
chop,
screaming.
If you could put together all the babies
being born,
coming out of pussies all at once and
getting their dicks circumcised
altogether and one screaming man.
It'd be a V,
a dubstep music video.
I think it would.
I think.
I think
you are underestimating the amount of
force can meet that gets generated by
the feed.
Like you hear about that guy who fell
into his hogs,
hogs,
the hogs Itam.
Yeah.
Pigs are a motherfucker,
man.
Pigs are a motherfucker.
They're so scary.
Big Fat,
stupid animals that would eat you if you
fall in their pay.
Anything.
Seven hundred pounds like this.
They just started chewing on.
I bet it was a quick death though.
Well they,
they fucked him up,
man.
You know,
they ate most of them before the people
even found like the guy went missing for
a few hours by the time they got there.
He was just disemboweled.
They had just eaten the shit out of him.
Well they,
yeah.
They couldn't even find him.
Yeah.
Most of them was missing.
It's really scary with a picket duty.
You.
It's like the Tibetans skier at your.
With both pigs.
Wild pigs are even better than that.
You don't even have to mash up the
bones,
the do it for you.
They'll take care of everything.
The pigs are,
uh,
you know,
they're responsible for more deaths per
year than any of the livestock.
That's crazy when you think about like
bowls.
But no.
Pigs are responsible for more deaths.
I had no idea.
Yeah.
Pigs are fucking for a wild pig.
Especially wild pigs are really creepy.
That just doesn't go through my list of
ways.
I might die that you've never seen the
pig show a pig man.
Now go pig hunting.
Dude.
It is one of the craziest shows that
I've ever seen on television.
Okay.
Is a guy named pig man and he lives in
south Texas and the pig.
The wild pig problem in south Texas is
like roaches in Manhattan.
I mean,
it is bananas.
You can't fucking believe how many pigs
there are and they're huge and they're
wild pigs.
It's what happens with pigs is a pig
when they leave the.
It's really weird.
When they leave captivity within three
weeks,
their body changes,
their snout starts to grow longer,
their hair gets thicker and bushier
their fans,
their tusks grow longer.
It's really weird,
like they physically morph and it starts
in just three weeks.
As soon as they have to fend for
themselves as soon as the food's not
continually delivered to them.
So you keep them in like this fetus
form.
When you continually deliver food to
them,
when you see pigs,
you see them,
they're fat and they're lazy and they're
just laying around and we just stuff
them and overstuff them and then
eventually slaughter them that they do
not even remotely resemble wild pigs.
Wild pigs are mother fuckers,
dude,
and they will attack you like this one
and this one show.
This guy shot a wild pig with two arrows
and it didn't kill it and the thing
charged them from the bushes and he's
unloading a pistol into it.
Blab,
blab.
Plan as a thing,
rushes him a death run.
It's with tusks and there are hundreds
of pounds,
three,
four,
500 pounds,
wild pigs,
and they're everywhere.
There are millions of them in Texas.
So this guy,
pig man and Ted nugent get a helicopter
and they're flying around in a
helicopter shooting these pigs out of
the sky,
shooting them from this guy.
It's.
It's insane.
They killed 200 pigs in a,
in a one hour show.
It's amazing the different lives people
are having.
Yes it is.
This guy is just fucking up pigs all
day.
What do you call Shanken?
I'm here to Shanghai,
Shanghai.
He's Shanken swag and he's like this
heavy duty southern,
you know,
a good old boy from south Texas.
It's a funny fucking.
It's a funny fucking show man.
Like you know when you play video games
and when you're going to bed,
if you played video games too much,
you kind of see him on the back of your
eyes if you ever done that.
Yes.
This guy,
when he goes to bed,
he just sees pigs and from a helicopter
shooting and shooting pig too.
They shoot them with assault rifles to.
I mean it's crazy.
It's.
They're swooping around this helicopter.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So why not grenades?
Because they actually use the meat.
Oh,
I see.
They,
they give the meat to a foreign foreign.
They'd give the meat to a poor.
He sent
me.
They sent the Meta Iran,
Afghanistan where all the boys wild
swine.
Nothing.
They love more than wow.
Poor.
Yeah.
That's how we really good at them.
We brought,
we import pigs because the Muslims,
they're not supposed to eat pork.
If we imported these 500 pound murdered
fucking hogs murdered from the sky,
death from above,
they do it to like apocalypse now,
Dr de Dah.
And it's called a pork lips.
Pork Lips.
Now I is,
it is.
It is a fucking insane show.
Um,
so there are no pigs in Iran.
that's a good question.
I don't know.
I do not know.
I know.
Uh,
yeah.
They're not supposed to eat them if it's
a Muslim country.
Right?
I mean,
you would offend a lot of people if you
were eating them because they eat their
own shit.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
It's sort of Gorilla Doni.
Correct.
Bush meat.
That's where it all starts.
That's where patient zero starts.
So gross.
You ate bad guerilla one night and then
you get aids.
There was some people eating thing in
Africa right now.
What do you think the aids grill.
It tasted like.
Not good tasting,
like old feet.
Just a gym,
but they were hungry.
It tastes like a cadaver.
Ugh.
Yeah.
It's got to be very human.
Like dirty game me than humans though.
What did that gorilla do to get aids?
Why?
Where did it?
The grill so many probably fucked it.
It's probably when you introduced like
human,
we're going to find out that all this
shit boils down to somebody had a
fucking animal somewhere.
All of it.
Where,
where's the swine flu come from?
Well,
the funny thing about pigs,
they'll just let you fuck.
I'm so people started getting swine flu,
chicken,
flu,
chicken virus.
You know,
that's the thing about flu's.
A lot of people don't know a lot of
them.
Um,
bird flus there,
the,
these fluids.
A lot of them,
they come from farms that come from
these crazy places where you stuff a
million animals on three acres and uh,
you know,
it smells like death.
And that's where diseases come from.
Yeah.
It's really weird.
Farms are fucking creepy man.
Like,
like cattle farms,
whether they butcher cows.
We went and did a fear factor on one of
them.
I got to tell you about this other guy
on fear factor tube goes with what we're
talking about earlier about religion.
Remind me,
but we went to this thing.
We had to do this a slaughterhouse
episode.
It was a fucked up show man where we
gave these people,
it was like a bathtub of blood and they
had a dunk their head in and pull out
these rings that grabbed them with their
face and pull out these rings and they
were just covered in blood and one guy
was,
he couldn't do it.
It was cold water.
The water.
I mean the blood rather was really cold
and it had to be 38 degrees because
otherwise it can go bad and then you
people sick.
So we had to change the blood for every
person.
I think that was polite.
Yeah,
well that's.
I think we had to do it for health
reasons.
I,
I forget,
but I remember being super,
super cold.
So anyway,
this guy starts going nuts and smashing
the blood.
I don't like the Hulk and screaming and
this guy had been in the parking lot
before the show.
He had been talking in his side view
mirror,
looking at a side view mirror and go,
you are a winner.
You,
you are going to press ahead.
Nothing will stop.
You cannot quit shit.
So this guy had some like serious,
like hangups in his mind with failure
when it comes to,
I don't understand you say you smashing
the blood.
Well like the hulk,
like here's a big bathtub full of blood
and he's going to like this splattering
all over everybody in him and he's
soaked in blood screaming and he was a
big guy.
He was a big dude.
He's like a football player and I'm
looking at this guy and this guy wants
to kick my ass.
Like this might be a real problem.
Like this is a big dude.
Like this guy would like,
he's like a fucking physically strong
guy.
Like if you want to kick your ass,
the very least someone's getting hurt
you.
This is going to be going to be some
chaos.
And I'm looking around with these,
these fucking cameraman.
They're all skinny guys smoking
cigarettes.
Most of them are completely out of
shave.
A lot of them are older guys were like
back problems.
I'm like,
no one's going to save me.
Who's going to save me if this guy goes
bananas?
That is fucking.
Yeah,
this dude right here,
apparently he was a really nice guy and
he felt real bad about his performance
on the show and he just said that he was
having some issues and he had had it
with like other sports in the past.
Yeah,
it was insane.
It was insane.
By the way,
I don't even remember this.
I'm watching this and I don't even
remember it.
I barely remember it.
Dante.
Oh,
inferno man.
That's demonic.
We did 148 of these fucking things.
Can you believe that shirt?
What a ridiculous job I had.
I'm screaming at these people,
giving them,
telling them they can do it
crazy.
This guy right here,
I saw you outside.
You were talking to this,
the side of the mirror.
What are you doing?
Psyching yourself up.
It's a story that goes back to my
football coach and he said,
little eyes upon you.
You know little kids watching you all
the time and the man in the class.
Look yourself in the mirror when you're
done and you say,
good job.
That's what I want to do.
You go home and you can't look at
yourself.
I don't want that,
man.
All right,
well,
you're going to be looking at yourself
in the mirror with a big fat face full
of blood.
What's going to happen now?
You're going to send Joseph home.
I'm going to do my best buddy.
I can't pull my head in there and then
go home and have people say,
man,
you did that for nothing.
Joshua.
You Ready?
Ready?
You beat 19.
Joseph goes home and you move on
in three,
two,
one.
So he quit right away and see how he's
screaming,
punching the blood,
get so nasty.
Look at that,
and he couldn't do it right now.
He keeps shaking,
shaking his face.
That's all I'm saying is.
See everybody else just went in there is
totally quitting.
Now,
here's what he starts freaking out.
Good instincts broke and I saw that
blood coming.
This is so ridiculous.
No,
I don't think so about that transfer
like an episode.
Incredible.
You.
I noticed how much different
my voice sounds before I got my nose
fixed.
Yeah,
I had a nasally sort of thing going on.
I had no nose for most of my life when I
got a deviated septum operation.
Completely changed my life.
Man.
I can't believe I went so long.
I have friends that have like fucked up
noses.
I'm like,
do please get your nose fixed.
Just please listen to me.
Get your nose fixed.
You're whole life.
You can be like a dog like this.
Here.
You realize it.
You know your whole life.
You get this fucking thing that's
blocking up air.
Did you hear about that millionaire that
did so much cocaine that his fucking
nose exploded?
Did not collapse.
Here's,
here's a.
here's this nosy like,
looks like boss Hog neck.
Oh damn this.
Let's just go down.
Jesus Christ.
Look at that.
Fucking knows.
Alright,
whatever you're using,
windows aren't you?
Got To stop enough.
I didn't know somebody that did so much
cocaine that,
uh,
his nose in between the nostrils,
like,
made a hole in between the two nostrils.
But to do a lot of,
that's like a goddamn commitment.
Do you think it collapsed all at once?
Like one night he woke up and I was
like,
that.
Or,
that guy's an ugly fuck and he doesn't
give a shit.
Anyway,
just trying to get my ged shock and get
my coke.
He's one of those can get my coke,
we'll get him.
The other dude that,
uh,
I want to talk about the fear factor
when a million dollars and he was going
to tie that.
He's just going to give them a 10
percent is church.
And the dude started talking in tongues.
He was talking in tongues like he was a
showman.
Zalia yeah.
Glossolalia.
Colossae.
Lelea.
Yeah.
Just how long they start talking and see
if he could put that up.
Pull that up,
man.
Fear factor.
Guy Speaks in tongues.
It was so bizarre that he won.
He Won.
He won a million bucks.
So maybe the dude just believes in
himself so much because of all this that
he forced the.
Well,
you know,
where that speaking of tongues comes
from right now,
after the Jesus,
our Lord died.
He,
um,
his disciples were all gathered together
in some,
like hiding out and like,
I think he appeared to them or the doors
opened and a wind blew through and
suddenly they were able to speak in
every language and they all started
speaking and all the languages of the
world.
That's the myth.
So pentecostal churches,
they will,
um,
try to induce this state,
you know,
I know you've seen it and they handle
rattlesnakes do because that was the
other thing.
He gave them power to take up serpents.
So they.
So they have these
rituals.
We handle rattlesnakes.
So what do they do?
They get bit,
a little bit.
Some of them,
they get bitten and they die.
Dude,
look up pentecostal snake handling.
He never seen that Rogan.
You've never seen snake handlers?
I've seen snakes.
They dance around with the snakes up in
the mountains.
There's a guy whose father died.
He was a snake handler and then he just
died really recently.
Who was one of those?
Those a snake handler guys.
Oh man,
that is just the fucking worst man.
That is the worst.
That's so creepy.
It's such the opposite of what that
religion.
It's so weird that Christianity managed
to mutate into like malnourished country
people talking and fake languages and
holding snakes on a Sunday.
That's fucking weird,
man.
Yeah.
It's a very weird.
It's so strange how religion can mutate
because like if you look at that versus
Catholicism,
it's two completely different things.
Yeah.
This is from a just from may serpent
handling pastor dies from rattlesnake
fight bite.
Just like his father.
Yeah.
He's in West Virginia.
Hala,
his faith wasn't strong.
Is that what they think?
Do they think that like their faith
failed and that's why the snake bit him
or
we did some traveling through West
Virginia and I got to just see some
really bizarre places.
Like one of them was um,
a bar that was a house.
It was a house and then the downstairs
was the bar.
I mean it was just,
they had like a plastic sign that said
bar.
And I mean it was a fucking house.
It was like somehow or another they had
converted their house into a bar.
It was so bizarre.
And then right next door was always a
church and then there was always a strip
club.
It was strip club,
church Bar,
strip club,
church bar.
That's all you had.
Weird shit goes on in those Hollers,
Joe and the uh,
and,
and a city next to where my mom lives.
This guy fucking hacked up.
His Dad sit through his limbs on the
Blue Ridge Parkway,
which is just up in the woods.
He was through his head,
the forest and then his arm somewhere
and then his arm somewhere.
A Betty wasn't a good dad.
That was,
I don't know,
I,
I asked my mom,
I was like,
yeah,
the dad's probably.
I realized that the exact same thing
where I blame the dad,
but she's like,
no,
it wasn't that,
you know,
the kid was just fucking crazy.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
regardless of how bad or daddy or I
don't know if you deserve to have your
limbs chopped off,
maybe.
Well there are exceptions.
Relentless for 20 years.
She deserved to get 20 years straight.
He just managed to crawl away to the
ash,
been trying to get to the expert 20
years,
and you never lost your heart on and
develop those strength just from
resisting ass rape.
Oh Man.
But that fucking goddamn idea that
people just walk from time to time this
member,
each other.
It's really strange that they're,
you know,
in the same way that what's his name
flies around blast and pigs.
You also know that at this very moment,
multiple limbs are being hacked off and
a variety of basements and back rooms
and force like definitely more than like
50 people at this very moment are
probably getting their arms chopped off.
Wolf,
how about this?
How about thinking about all the people
in different parts of the world that
have to walk around on the ground
knowing that they're killing machines
flying over their sky every day at any
point in time.
You could be the wrong place at the
wrong time and a hell fire missile comes
out of one of these fucking flying
killer robots and annihilates a house
that you're standing next to
Predator drones.
That shit's intense.
And when you think about the future,
we've talked about this,
but I don't think we've talked about
this on the podcast,
which is that when you see those Goddamn
quadra copters that can fly perfect
formations,
and then you see those dogs that they've
used that.
What's that dog called?
Know the robot dog,
because people don't understand that.
If they can make that thing that size,
they can make it bigger.
They can make that thing real fucking
big so that you've got truck sized robot
dogs lumbering into your village opening
up slats.
That quadric copters fly out of blast.
Everyone in the village,
you know,
cremate them or whatever,
suck them into the dog and walk away.
That could be the future of warfare.
It's like a Trojan horse at Trojan horse
filled with Quadra copters.
Yeah,
that's completely possible.
And not.
Not even remotely outside the realm of
possibility because where do you think
that they're?
They're learning how to build these
robots.
It's Darpa.
Darpa is creating these robot dog
Darpa stand for.
Oh,
that's a good question.
Darpa gives me that fucking creeps.
Every time I see any Darpa rate later
thing,
it's always
defense.
Advanced Research Projects Agency.
Jesus.
What is scary?
That's patient.
We named that the scary concern.
Crazy.
They're just finding new ways to fuck
people up.
That's what they do.
It's funny how we like to call it
defense.
How much money we're gonna spend on
It's seems pretty authentic.
Our offense budget.
Yeah,
it's our offense budget.
Really.
It shit like robot dogs.
Come on son.
Those things are fucking terrifying.
Robot dogs.
You can't kick over.
They'd get back up.
Brian,
pull up.
One of those.
Darpa robot does is actually a new
version that just came out.
I'm looking at it right now on the Darpa
website.
It is horrific sound.
It makes that kind of Hell's squeals and
it makes.
Dude,
this thing is terrifying.
It goes up hill.
Oh,
I'm looking at this video before Brian
pulls it up and it doesn't even seem
real.
It looks like CGI.
This thing is walking up hills.
It can negotiate over rocks and terraces
and it's built like a bowl.
Do you think they could make that the
size of a bus?
Yeah.
Fuck yeah,
they could.
Darpa legged squad support system.
How'd you get to that video?
I went to Darpa.com
and then what'd you click on Darpa?
They have.
There's a little image of it all right
here.
You see in the lower right hand corner
and then the lower left.
It looks like a dog running at Ya.
That's it.
Click on that.
I love the way you figured out how to
embed advertising into your podcasts.
We know you're sponsored by Darpa.
Joe.
I'm not sponsored by robot dogs.
You can't buy.
That doesn't even make sense.
Would it use coupon code Rogan at Darpa?
Look at this fucking thing,
man.
That's like the giant robot bowl.
Imagine this thing.
Had machine guns and then rocket ports.
This things coming over the hill.
You don't shoot shooting Mrs
[inaudible].
One of those things is coming over the
hill.
300 of those things coming over.
They build one of these motherfuckers.
They they're going to build a million
pound of 300 of those things at once is
the last thing.
A lot of people are going to hear.
This music has creeped me out.
I want to hear this thing,
Brian.
I want to hear that noise.
It makes.
Hold on.
Imagine 300 locusts.
They're playing.
Follow the leader now it can follow.
Oh,
they follow each other?
Holy Shit.
It's like it's got a face in there too.
That is not following him.
That's what follow the leader is.
I don't want it to fall in.
Oh my God.
They're calling a follow the leader.
Not Chase you and hunt you down.
Isn't that cute?
They call it follow the leader.
Oh,
that's so sweet.
Follow the leader.
Look at this thing.
It's liners back.
Fucking goddamn terrifying.
Oh fine.
They can dance.
Oh my God.
Look at the scanners on them and shit.
Reading what's in front of them.
So scary.
That is so holy fuck kids.
Woo.
Yeah,
that's spooky shit man.
And when you combine that with those
quadra copters man,
it's not just that the quadra copters
and if you ever have you seen that
thing,
they can jump off of buildings and we'll
just.
That alone is terrifying.
That thing is.
That thing is horrendous that that's a
robot dog,
a giant robot dog that can house
missiles and anything you want to
fucking anything you want.
Those things would probably super
strong.
They can carry all sorts of metal
fucking things that kill people on them
and they look like they look like they
weren't going to stop.
That just looked like it wasn't going to
stop.
Like it's like you couldn't get away
from them.
They would never stopped at.
Keep coming.
Yeah,
and even if they did stop a repair swarm
of quadric opters would come down and
fix it.
You're not gonna.
You can't beat it.
You're not gonna be able to beat that
kind of technology and mass that scale
that is just as frightening almost as an
atomic bomb because it's just as
heartless and cold and it's just.
It's going to do what someone said that
someone has to do is press the button,
send it out there,
and they sort of alleviate themselves of
any responsibility because it's the
robot that's going to go in there and
fuck things up.
And also there's this ridiculous notion
that humans still seem to have that
these computers are never going to
become autonomous.
Of course.
Yeah.
I mean,
at one point in time,
every single programmer that has ever
made anything that you use on your
computer has had to contemplate where
the fuck that's going?
Where the fuck the,
the anybody who's talking about
artificial intelligence,
anyone is talking about it,
they all say it's going to get too
upset.
The important.
They all say yes.
And it's almost like we don't.
We're like little kids that have a
credit card and we're just going to keep
running up the bill until the check
comes and then we're going to go,
fuck,
how do we pay this?
Oh wait,
what have we done?
Oh Shit,
we're fucked.
Yeah.
Like we're gonna.
We're gonna create this artificial thing
that is way fucking smarter than us and
realizes how gross we are.
Look at that thing that's on the sheet a
robot.
It goes up to 28 miles.
Look at that thing going.
Oh my God,
that's scary.
That is fucking terrifying.
Scary.
Looking at Komen,
but again,
25 miles an hour running after you
imagine 200 of those running down hill.
It's not.
It's not just one.
They just don't unleash one name.
Only sworn in there.
They have.
They're covered in
machetes.
Can Be like a transformer can be bad at
Weiss.
Everyone hates underneath.
Yeah.
They found out that cutting things apart
is cheaper than shooting missiles and
guarantee they're going to have drones
that can figure out how to turn human
blood and the energy.
It's just.
It's just weird to me that you know that
this is all happening inside of our
life,
that this is all going on right now.
I mean we really are seeing robots that
can run 25 miles an hour.
We really are seeing drones shoot
missiles.
It's like it seems like some shit from a
movie,
but it's really happening right now and
there really are people that are
programming computers and programming,
artificial intelligence,
and they really are going to get it to a
point where it can think for itself and
there really are going to get to a point
where it can make its own decisions and
where it can decide to improve itself.
Auto bots doing this is really happening
in our life.
We really might be in this glory day
before the scene and the terminator.
I mean that's.
That's that,
that it's within the realm of
possibility of robots do become sentient
and then especially if they need more
power,
the question is the type of singularity
that's not if the singularity is going
to happen,
but the type of singularity that happens
and that.
The big question is an advanced
intelligence that we made machines that
becomes autonomous.
Are they going to view us as just a
waste of time and just decide to wipe us
out or.
I think that the other alternative is
far more likely.
Are they going to see that we're a
resource in the same way?
Like they would probably see everything
as a,
a bit of information that they could use
to transform and create whatever the
thing is that they've decided is a more
perfect universe.
So I think it's more likely that they're
going to assimilate with us than it is
that they would just chop as to bits
because we are rudimentary bio
computers.
They certainly are gonna have some use.
You know,
I think that I think it's going to be
more about connectivity than destroying.
Well the real issue is how do you
program into an artificially intelligent
being the need to improve or the desire
to improve or the need to progress.
It's like just because something is
intelligent and capable of incredible
things and capable of thinking on its
own doesn't mean it's going to have
those human style ambitions that allow
us or cause us to make like a lot of the
things that we make,
the things that we make we make because
of this weird competitive drive that we
have because of this weird desire to
innovate and improve and create things.
These are like characteristics that have
led us to not be monkeys.
They've lead us away from the lower
hominids and we don't know that a
computer would have these
characteristics,
these characteristics that lead people
to work all day and busted her ass and
you know,
and in,
in acquiring material goods and be a
baller and all that stuff.
Those,
there's a weird instinct,
but the,
the what if those instincts inside of us
are not just inside of us,
but our manifestations of a kind of
evolutionary energy that's rolling
through time and as it rolls through
time,
it gets more and more complex and more
and more harmonized.
Which manifests in the form of evolution
in the form of single celled organisms
becoming multicell organisms all the way
up to us.
This is an actual energy that in the
same way wind blows through trees and
moves trees.
When this energy blows through the world
or through time,
it causes things to wake up and connect.
And in that case,
whatever happens to be in,
in that wind,
in that energy is going to just wake up.
And that's what it does.
So in that case,
it's not as though the computers need to
be programmed,
they just need to be fine tuned enough
to start picking up that energy.
And once they pick it up,
that's when the,
um,
the,
uh,
whatever this point is,
that's assuming that something that's
not natural.
Something that was created by life,
not,
not born in a natural way is going to
inherit the same sort of desires to,
to progress forward.
You know,
I think that the universe certainly is
getting more and more complex.
Like everything.
If you look at the idea of the big bang
that's there was a single point smaller
than the head of a pin.
The giant explosion creates everything
we see in the sky today.
That just that alone,
like then it has to cool down and then
planets are formed and stars explode and
carbon based life forms based out of
star,
but we have,
we have.
We literally have to have a star has to
explode for you can make a person.
A lot of people don't really understand
that you,
you,
you look at that.
Just that idea that in that person might
very well one day harness the power to
make a star explodes.
I mean that person could,
if you exponentially increase the rate
of our destructive capabilities,
if you look at like 19,
47 when they first,
was it 45,
47 when they perfected the atomic,
oh,
I don't know,
the year,
whatever year that is,
looked at as the forties and look at
2012.
What they could do now destroy the
entire earth like 100 times over if
Russia and the United States and
Pakistan,
everybody just launched their nukes.
Everybody launched.
Every nuke we've ever made was.
It was.
It would be crazy.
I mean,
it would be nothing left on the planet.
The whole planet would be done.
Well,
if you extrapolate 100 years from now,
you know,
200 years from now,
what kind of destructive anti-matter
weapons are we going to have?
Then we're going to have star killers.
You know,
we're,
we're most certainly going to have to
have the ability to erase things.
A race planets.
It's just gonna happen.
What you made me think I've man is like,
I've always thought that idea that we
are star energy that's woken up because
the elements are the result of fusion
happening inside of stars.
I've always thought were eight
degradation of the energy of the stars.
Where are the energy getting weaker or
weakening down?
But what if actually worst our energy
getting immensely more powerful.
Only the power is manifesting as
intelligence or consciousness.
And,
and what if the this destructive thing
that you're talking about,
it doesn't come from weapons,
but from innovation and,
and,
and this is this,
this is why I fucking love Kurzwell
because he's,
he talks about this idea that it gets to
the point where we begin to manipulate
matter at the atomic level and this
somehow spreads out into space where,
where Nan Nan,
swarms of nanobots just fly through the
universe reconstructing matter according
the whims of whatever the overmanned is
or whatever the,
the force of intelligence that is a
result of everything connecting is now
that's fucking a million times more
powerful than a star.
It's something totally brand new.
It's like a novelty.
Explosions.
I think there's no doubt whatsoever that
people are probably very much like a lot
of other animals that create byproducts
without even understanding why they're
doing it.
You know,
there's a lot of bees making honey.
I mean they make honey to feed their
offspring of their.
They're little,
but they also pollinate flowers.
They do,
they do.
They do a lot of like weird tasks.
Like they,
they help things move along in
pollinating plants.
You really like help things move along,
right?
You,
you,
you're,
you're aiding in the process I think are
crazy.
Need to acquire things is aiding in the
process of technological innovation at
the highest speed possible.
I think it's one of the reasons why it's
so compelling to get new phones and a
new laptop.
Dude,
you got the new laptop.
Oh Shit.
Let me see.
Look at that fucking screen.
It's sexual man.
I mean it's sexy as fuck.
You can get a really dope phone.
You hold it and you scroll through it
and like it's.
There's something.
There's something alluring about that
technology.
I think our desire to continue to have
bigger,
better,
badder,
faster or more awesome or I think that
is.
That's the number one thing that's
pushing innovation.
The number one thing that's pushing
technology is this desire for all these
new objects and as that technology gets
pushed further and further and further,
more becomes possible until you really
develop reality changing technologies.
I mean the atomic bomb is essentially a
reality.
Changing technology.
Electricity is reality.
Changing the Internet's reality.
Change is d reality changed for sure,
but it's essentially inevitable.
It's like it's going to keep going and
going and going.
As long as the humans don't blow
themselves up with one of their reality
changing things,
they're going to come up with something
like a time machine come up with
something like some sort of a
transportation device or transport or a
beamer.
They're going to be able to scramble
your fucking cells and reconstruct them
on the moon.
I mean,
they're gonna be able to do anything
they want eventually.
If if time keeps going on and people
don't get killed by asteroids or blow
themselves up.
It's just inevitable.
It's an inevitability for sure.
It's inevitable and you can kind of feel
it,
and I know it sounds so stupid,
but whenever I fucking go without
playing a video game for a long time and
buy a brand new video game and play it,
it really fills me with a kind of.
I love it,
but it's kind of ominous and how amazing
they are getting,
how potent they are getting.
You know that.
You used to talk about this,
how our nervous systems might not be
built for the massive amounts of sense
gratification that are accessible
through technology and we it hijacks
your reward system.
Borderlands two,
I just started playing this game.
Holy Shit Man.
It's such a perfect game.
Not just like graphics wise,
which are really trippy,
kind of like heavy metal magazine
trippy,
but like the game itself is the first
game that's ever made me laugh.
It's kind of funny.
They've added a weird humor to it.
They get good voiceover actors and it's
super violent,
but it's so narcotic that it's really
makes me understand that this technology
is a drug.
It's a drug that they haven't identified
yet as a drug,
but it's a fun.
It's exactly like any other drug.
Well maybe not even like any other drug
like heroin it.
Well,
porn is also a drug.
Yes.
Porn,
especially the immediate access to porn
online.
It's a drug.
I mean it is a drug.
There's no question about it.
You know,
I was watching and Dr drew episode the
other day where there's a dude who was
addicted to porn.
Fucking fascinating,
fascinating looking at this guy and his
wife and you know them trying to work
out intimacy again because this guy was
just fucking completely whacked off on,
beat it off to to check some online.
It's a man.
It's a pull.
It's like a technology has a gravity and
you and it's a gravity that doesn't
operate on mass.
It operates on a tension,
so when you're around technology,
you can feel it.
Drawing your attention into it,
the thing you were talking about with
your phone,
with porn,
with TV,
with your car,
you're fucking new car.
Whatever it is,
it pulls at your mind in this very
obvious way that's impossible to deny
and that that energy,
that is the beginning of the connection
that machines are making with our
neurology.
That's the very first contact.
When you feel that pole,
you're filling feeling the force of
technology linking into your nervous
system.
You're feeling an interface happen at a
very rudimentary level,
but that interface is going to get more
and more focused,
more and more advanced and more and more
perfect until it'll lock in for good.
Do you think people back in the day
though thought that about books like
when blood these books,
man,
they're teaching us.
Well,
they didn't know when they first
invented printing.
That's one of the things that held Islam
back was that they didn't allow it to be
printed with the typeset.
It was only allowed to be like written
down and there was a.
It was a long time before they allowed
the Koran to be printed.
Well,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
Well fuck them up.
That's the thing about relisted print
was the beginning of the devil and while
they were in the same camp as the
unabomber was a brilliant guy who they
whacked out with Lsd Studies.
Yeah.
I think there's no question.
We have some bizarre attraction to
technology and there's no question that
we're not set up to handle that type of
sensory overload that they provide.
Where when
when a guy goes on a screen and you
know,
and his fucking face is 60 feet high and
he says the perfect shit because there's
a team of writers who spent weeks going
over his dialogue with a fine tooth comb
and his music.
There's music playing when he's talking.
I mean it's the impact is pretty fucking
intense.
The hero impact that you get from a
movie.
Yeah.
That's if you could,
if you could take someone from the 15
hundreds and and,
and bring them to a movie theater and
get them to watch like Avatar.
They,
they would shriek in horror.
They would cry and scream.
They would be weeping and fascination.
They wouldn't believe what they were
saying.
They would.
They would think that they were in the
presence of God himself.
If you played a movie and God was in a
fucking robe and old man and a robe can
make magic shit happen,
and you showed on the screen God,
like making things happen,
all kinds of crazy special effects.
They would buy it,
hook,
line and sinker 100 percent because it
would be beyond the realm of
imagination.
It'd be completely beyond.
So the question is,
my thing was that were setup like that
guy though our biology is like that guy,
our biology hasn't changed,
but what we introduced to it on a
regular basis has changed significantly.
It's,
it's getting and it's getting more and
more powerful every day and it induces a
trance state.
And so the question is,
what are we like when we're not in a
trance state?
What does that look like?
Because I don't know if you're without
your phone for an hour,
you feel a little weird.
Like if you forget your phone at your,
at you feel weird.
So because the state of consciousness
that we're in now,
we have become dependent on the machine.
The machine has become part of us.
So what is,
what are we like outside of that trance
state,
outside of that stupor.
What uh,
what are we like when our consciousness
or our attention isn't getting drawn
into some glowing screen?
And before that,
what is it,
our consciousness like when it's not
being drawn into a book or a religion,
is there a pure state or.
We always like constantly in relation to
something.
Is there a way that you're not in a
trance or are you always consistently
connecting with some symbols structure
out there,
you know?
Well,
unless you live in the woods and go
offline for a while and you're
connecting in one tiny bit,
you mean it's like you have your finger
on home base,
you're scared to run away from it.
You're safe,
you're safe.
You get your finger on home base.
How many times have you been at a
restaurant and you're looking at your
phone?
It's just compelling.
You check,
you can check it,
check,
check.
Using link that you can use.
If you don't check your twitter.
Endless.
It's endless.
And,
and,
and it's,
I mean,
I,
I will admit,
man,
I'm addicted to the Internet.
There's no question.
My behavior is addictive behavior.
I am addicted to information.
I love it.
I love every weird little fucking thing,
man.
The fact that I,
you know,
the amazing leopard attack video that
came out today,
or
what is the video?
It's a leopard in a gorilla.
Is that okay?
It's a fucking.
It's a,
it's a leopard leaping it something,
but I was on the fucking airplane and
couldn't watch it.
I try.
I spent 30 minutes trying to watch that
fucking thing just because I was so
interested in it.
But when you consider that 10 years ago,
15 years ago,
if you wanted to see something like
that,
you'd have to be sitting in front of a
big ass TV and before that if you wanted
to see something like that,
you'd have to go out in the woods and
find it to see it.
You know,
it's,
it's the,
the,
the things that we are witnessing as
human beings in this time period or
things that most human beings in the
past would see one of them in their
entire lives if that,
if that.
The thing is that these things are
coming out as constantly all the time.
So our senses are just on overload.
Just a 100 percent overload.
Yes,
and we don't,
we don't have the ability to process
whether or not those rewards are being
utilized in a natural manner.
It's like a,
it's like a parasite system.
It's like the story of that,
uh,
aquatic worms that infects the
grasshopper and literally talks the
grasshopper into committing suicide,
just gets inside of its brain,
tells it what to do.
And then,
and then hatch's Brian,
if you pull up an animal face off
gorilla versus leopard,
I think that's the video,
but maybe that's what technology is
doing with us.
Maybe it's sort of embedded itself
slowly but surely into our system and
more and more and more,
it's getting to the point where you
can't function without it.
It's
beyond that point.
If you know the thing where they talk
about if the sun solar flares do much
and knocks out all the GPS satellites,
the havoc it'll wreak on this planet.
It's way past the point of no return.
We've got to have the connection.
We must have it for our society to work
for trucks,
to deliver food for fucking nuclear
plants to work.
If this shit shuts down,
you know and shit
on the ropes.
Yeah,
you got to fast forward quite a bit
before the actual action.
That's fake news.
That was an artificial leopard.
Look at these fucking through.
These are real.
They're having fights in the trees.
What a scary ass animal.
Leopards are scary too,
because they're there.
They're really quick.
The arms can you do.
I've never seen this guerrilla fighting
elaborate.
These gorillas duking it out to shake
off.
We have that leverage is jack and that
absolute.
Oh my God.
That is crazy.
The senses are as sharp as our size of
that fucking thing could keep the
leopard and edge.
I would say gorilla would when I say,
oh,
look at that.
Predict who will win only to find out.
I don't know man.
I wish animals have police.
The grill might.
When they look pretty fucking crazy.
The grill might just rip that thing
apart in our scenario of,
Oh,
this is a scenario.
You sons of bitches,
so this is all fake.
It's not just ones that are real though,
isn't there?
Like,
this is so dumb in our scenario,
in our crap.
It's like a bad video game.
Oh my God,
this is awful.
This is a video game for the eighties
produce.
This is what happens when the budget
runs out.
Yeah.
This isn't the video.
Is there another video or is this the
one you were talking about is awesome
because like.
Yeah,
definitely.
This is 100 percent horseshit.
Well,
there you go.
You were addicted to watching that
though.
You really wanted to see it.
It drew you in.
It was real.
That's the thing man,
and it's like the.
There's like a lot of meditative
practice practices are all about like
developing your focus and developing
your will through developing your focus
and when your mind is getting pulled in
a million different directions by your
phone and by the computer and buy tv
than it really does seem like you are.
It's like eating too much,
too many sweets.
You know,
like you're some innate part of you is
going to start rotting.
You're gonna lose this really important
focus like men,
you know when you get around someone
who's got real focus,
who's really,
really figured out a way to pin to turn
their minds into a pinpoint,
like a laser fucking Tom cruise does it
from the scientology training.
Have you ever seen him?
You know,
like when he gets,
when he gets sprayed,
so he gets to blow my hair.
I mean that dude.
I don't,
I,
I wouldn't be surprised.
I'm sure there's a lot of power in that,
but we're so distracted right now that
when you come across someone who's got
that kind of focus,
you almost feel like you're around
Dracula or something.
It's kind of creepy when someone's like
just tunes in salesmanship.
Do you think that that would work on you
though?
If you and Tom Cruise,
we're alone in a room together and you
had a conversation with suck his dick.
Stop.
If you are alone in a room with him,
don't you think that he would appear
silly if we talked to them just for a
couple of hours?
Oh yeah.
He would be a silly person.
Like did you ever see him in Matt Lauer?
Never.
See that.
The conversation with a lady that got on
the subject of scientology and his
criticism of Brooke shields taking
antidepressants,
that's a fascinating dude,
man.
He would curl rumble like a house of
cards.
Okay.
You think he's charismatic?
I think he's only charismatic if you're
really dumb.
If you watch that video and you see like
the way he communicates when he talks
about,
you know,
match pink glum.
You're glum like,
he's like,
he's like a silly person.
Like,
well,
yeah.
It has to be protected.
Yeah,
he will.
He's got an entourage around him and
people who are probably better at
hypnotizing,
but yeah,
as a brilliant actor,
I don't.
I don't think I get sucked in by that
from Tom Cruise,
but I think that what you're saying,
but talking about Tom Cruise
having this.
Yeah man,
I think there's.
I think it's an example of people.
What is that?
Was that,
but we have video game tech Demo.
Oh Wow.
That's
fucking insane.
Crazy.
Oh my God.
Look at the facial features.
This guy is like making all these
different facial features or a gestures.
That's incredible.
That's really weird.
That's crazy.
Creepy and it's going to get going to
get crazy.
It's gonna be hard to kill people in
video games.
You're gonna start feeling guilty.
This is the new real listening engine
where it's supposed to look like a real,
as realistic as it looks like a video.
This is quake like it looks like a
camera.
You're going down.
That looks so realistic.
If you told me this is a real video,
I would say,
yeah,
that's a video.
Someone's got their iphone.
Amazing.
That's incredible,
but my,
my,
my thing was I just don't think that you
would be impressed with his focus.
I think that's nonsense.
I think that's only.
That's only when you see him in
interviews and he puts on this thing and
I think alone.
You would think that would be silly.
No,
I,
I think I.
I'll give you a list of people.
I don't know why I started with Tom
Cruise.
Probably a bad idea,
but you see that focus in.
I'm like politicians a lot.
Like Obama's got it.
Even fucking Romney has this weird way
that he kind of does the heat seeking
missile lock in on people when they're
talking.
It's different from the way normal
people act and that level of focus comes
from being supremely disciplined in some
way or another.
You know,
whether it's because you're having to,
as a politician,
like if you think about the level of
focus it takes for those guys during the
debates,
regardless of whether you liked them or
not.
When you imagine that one misstep,
one each one wrong thing that you say is
going to get repeated like a strobe
light for the next week or perhaps could
ruin your chance at being president.
That's an insane amount of pressure that
they're under and they've developed some
incredible focus that deal with it,
which I think is different than most
other people.
You know,
most people are scattered,
man.
I eat dinner with people sometimes and
they can't go four minutes without
checking their phone.
You know,
you just get used to it.
You get used to this thing around people
where it's like,
oh yeah,
they're one of those people who always
check their phone.
Like I know during a conversation with
this person,
they're going to be constantly looking
at their phone,
irresistibly drawn to it.
It's the worst.
Yeah.
There's some people that they can't.
You can't lock in with them if they have
a phone on them.
No,
they can't resist it.
They don't even know they're doing.
Where it gets really creepy is where
your mid conversation with someone and
they just go down to the phone.
Oh yeah,
another dose.
Well,
the worst is like there'll be in the
middle of something and then it'll stop
and start texting and you're like,
hey man,
are we hanging out?
What's going on here?
Is this really that important?
You're going to stop in the middle of
talking like you stopped talking,
you started going hold on file.
It's vitally,
it's silly because most of the time it's
not that important.
What could it be?
It's most likely pussy.
Some of that sweet.
That's the other thing.
The robots are going to have no desire
for pussy,
so how are these life forms can even get
out of bed?
There's no no fucking reward system set
up.
I think that you are at being incredibly
optimistic thinking that robots are
going to give up.
They're going to pull the cord,
they're gonna realize how pointless life
is and before they ever get to recreate
it,
they're just going to blow themselves
up.
The robots.
Yeah,
they're gonna realize what's the point
where robots would have souls ever.
Nothing got nothing.
Just send 10 robot fucking circuits
going off,
switch flipping back and forth.
The singularity happens and they're just
a bunch of depressed.
They're homeless,
homeless robots because they have no
ambition.
It's and then we have to figure out
whether or not we want to put ambition
of the robots because then they'll
surely take over.
There'll be a big dilemma to be a bunch
of more list or like we have to give
them ambition.
We gave them life.
They're like,
Pinocchio.
He wants to be a real boy.
I think it's very likely that they will
have no desire whatsoever.
Unless it's programmed into them.
There's no reason for them to want to
fuck.
There's no reason for them to want money
or a big house.
I mean they're.
They're robots.
The what the fuck is the point in
advancing.
What's the point in making more robots
like what are.
What's the point of even being alive?
It's like it doesn't.
There's not going to be any reward.
The whole,
the whole like mo momentum that pushes
us towards all this technological
innovation and towards progress is these
weird reward systems that we have.
These reward systems are engineered by
the universe to ensure that we keep
pushing forward and all of the these
reward systems are all like going after
these primal reward systems that have
been inside of us for like hunting and
gathering and cold as a reward system
that it wants a common cold.
Is it,
is it.
Does it have ambition?
Is it going for something?
It's just,
it's just doing its thing.
Yeah,
but we know that we're not a cold.
We have actual were more complicated,
but viruses,
computer viruses don't have ambition
there.
They've just been coded to do something
right,
but they don't act.
They react the.
When a computer virus gets into your
system,
reacts to the fact that it can get in
and then it moves forward.
If this didn't get in,
it just stops.
Right.
This point here is like the beginning of
like an endless argument that you can
have because the point is do we act or,
or are we just.
Well,
my point was the computer viruses are
programmed to do things.
They're programmed to behave in a
certain way.
They go,
they try to go in if they can get past
step one to get in the right.
I mean that's how a computer virus is
set up.
We would have to make these computers
make these sentient beings.
We have to program them with some sort
of ambition,
some sort of desire to move forward
because if you didn't program them with
a,
with an objective,
a mandate,
if you didn't,
then they would just be intelligent just
because they're intelligent.
There's no reward system for them to
want to make a new nuclear reactor.
Again.
Man,
it's like you're creating a situation
where the robots are different than us
non-writers thing where it's like
they're not an expression of us or an
expansion of us.
You know,
they could be us as they could.
They could take what we are.
Our brains,
for example,
which is what is creating all the
simulation theory forever.
Once they take a human brain scan than
neurons in it,
ron energy through it and replicated
inside a machine will now you have
ambition now
consciousness.
Wow,
that's a big leap.
I think you have matter.
You have organic matter that will move
and react.
Did the.
The idea of consciousness being
completely local is a fairly
controversial idea.
There's a lot of people that don't
believe that consciousness even resides
in the mind.
You know,
if you want to get all woo with it,
they believe that consciousness is like
radio signals in your body is
essentially
really good antenna.
There's no way except to be speculative
about this.
No,
it hasn't happened yet,
so why would you?
But I would speculate that if you're
going to recreate a human mind inside a
computer,
I would speculate that the thing is
going to.
If you want to say that there's
consciousness that is exteriorized,
then I would say that that brain would
be an antenna for it in the same way
that our brains are.
That to me is like saying that if you
recreate it,
a car would start itself.
I don't think it's the same thing
because cars never start themselves.
Human brains are innately awake.
They're innately Sarah.
Create an artificial baby and let this
baby live life and learn all the things
that a person learns to develop a
personality or you can have somehow
another download.
Someone's already formulated 80 year old
personality into this,
this,
this creature.
Well,
I think that you've got a lot of
choices.
I mean,
it's literally the ideas.
If we take the neural pathways of the
human brain and replicate them inside a
machine,
the question that we're coming up
against as does the thing is,
will the thing think?
Will it be
well,
not only that will will the thing be a
person?
Will it grow old or does it just exists
in the state that you created in?
Are you able to create not just a
person,
but the mechanisms inside of a person,
the genetic coding that allows a person
to continue to grow and get older and
move forward?
There's a lot.
There's a lot of questions because is it
just a meat bag?
You know what?
If that would be really creepy if we
created a person and then just nothing
clicked.
It's just a meat bag that just dumb as
fuck.
Meanwhile it's got the most advanced
mind ever.
We checked the switches,
everything's on no desire to move
forward,
you know,
and then we developed a robot woman to
suck his Dick and then all of a sudden
he's out there huffing.
He's got a Ferrari.
He got a boat.
Hmm.
It's an interesting idea.
Is an amazing fucking drug and in a
definitely no one can argue with the
fact that it has been the carrot in
front of a lot of people's ambition,
washing a lot.
Why don't you say all the.
The idea of to be loved is in front of
almost anything
I guess.
All.
Yeah.
I mean I guess I'm just thinking like
maybe there's a.
I don't know.
It is.
It.
Is it peace.
It is a piece.
It might not be your entire expression,
but it's a piece of your motivation for
doing anything.
It's to be loved or the love of what
you're doing.
The love of what you're doing ultimately
is a better way of approaching it and
you know,
and you know,
you get love from doing that.
Well,
and it's a,
it's kind of a strange little,
uh,
it's sort of a strange little exchange.
Like if you concentrate too much on,
on getting love for what you're doing,
then you're not going to do good stuff.
You have to concentrate on being loving
what you're doing and then when you love
what you're doing and really focus on it
and then you get love from it.
Yeah.
It got me the trick.
Occurs.
Sure.
Don't you feel like that with comedy?
Yes.
The moment you get outside of that,
you are fucked man.
Well,
this is that,
that's in the,
in the Bhagavad Gita.
The versus you have a right to your
actions and not the fruit of your
actions,
which means you just focus on what
you're doing and don't worry about
what's going to flourish on the tree.
And then everything works out much
better.
Well,
that sounds like socialism to me,
Duncan.
And that's what that sounds like.
Fucking Bhagavad Gita.
Queer,
old,
shitty fucking writing.
What else does it tell you to do?
Yeah,
I think that it's,
um,
it's one of the sure ways to destroy
yourself is when you start worrying
about,
um,
or you can't.
By the way.
It's unavoidable.
Well,
have you ever had a conversation with
your agent about how to improve your,
your,
your response from the audience?
Got to give the people what they want.
No,
thank God.
You know,
you're going to think like why is pretty
cool.
Jamie Masada would give the worst
fucking advice in the history of the
world to comics and number one of them.
I mean,
look,
Jamie's a great guy.
He's got a great club,
but nobody can tell you what can make
you funny.
You are,
you and Duncan trussell's fund is going
to be different than jody is funny going
to be different than Brian.
Red Bands.
Funny.
We all got a weird way of looking at
things and you gotta figure out your
way,
but when you get a guy who's not a comic
that comes along with like the worst
advice ever.
Jamie Masada was this one dude.
He's like,
buddy,
you are the generation x guy.
That is your thing.
Everything you say will say,
my generation,
I'm generation x and that's your ag.
And the guy was like,
what the fuck are you talking about man?
Fucking generation x guy.
If I ever told you about who's opening
the door here,
if I ever told you about the advice that
my first manager gave me.
No.
So he saw me.
This was years and years and you've
locked the store.
Just the case before creeps.
You're walking in.
This place is not exactly secure.
It was.
Brian got up years and years ago I.
He saw me with wet hair and he's like,
that's what your thing could be.
You could be.
The guy always gets on stage.
What?
Oh,
that's an awesome piece of advice.
Did you think about for a second?
Not even for a second.
Like what is that even?
I guess.
I guess what I was thinking like,
well I'd probably get electrocuted for
one,
but what's,
what is that?
What's the joke?
Hey guys,
I just got wet.
Would you remember when you were doing
open mic?
Where there were guys who would have
like a very specific sort of fucking
stick.
Yes.
They were doing like they would have an
outfit.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
I've heard of.
I heard it.
Didn't you hear the tone?
You know the story of Jackie?
Jackie Banana.
Oh,
crazy.
Bob.
You know the story of Jackie Banana.
Jackie banana comic,
right.
Buzz.
He didn't he have like a funny act,
like a fake act.
I heard Mitzi just told him he had to
wear a banana,
a banana colored suit with a banana peel
hanging out.
Is he the guy that I'm thinking about
this.
There's a guy that had like this,
uh,
like sort of a throwback act,
sort of a Vaudevillian sort of a,
of a gesture to Vaudeville.
Is that the guy?
I don't know.
It was really like Hacky,
but purposely hacky on purpose is that
the guy doesn't know.
There's a comic.
Kind of like that,
Neil.
I'm not talking about Neil Hamburger.
I'm talking about.
There was another guy who is from years
ago.
It was like a skinny,
handsome sort of a guy who had this.
Is Jackie something or another?
I don't know,
Jackie diamond,
is that,
I'm sorry,
I can't remember the guy's name,
but he had like this.
It was pretty funny act,
but it was a.
It was like,
it was like you could have seen him in
a,
you know,
19 fifties mobster movie.
He'd be the guy on stage one of the
speakeasies or something.
Yeah.
Or you know,
most comedy way back in the day used to
have to have some shtick.
It didn't.
It wasn't like you could just like go
off and weird directions.
Comics were very sticky back in the
eighties.
There were a lot of sticky comics.
We'll look at Larry the cable guy.
That's his thing.
When you ever see the video of him doing
his reelect,
know him,
his real self as Dan.
It's really interesting.
No,
it was a comic and then he just took me
totally talks different when he took on
this thing and he's a very nice guy.
I've only hung out with him once,
but he was a very nice guy who's back in
the 19 nineties.
We did Montreal together and hung out at
the comedy works and he sent us some,
uh,
is a potato chips.
He has potato,
he listens to the podcast and he sent us
some potato chips that taste like
hamburgers.
Wow.
It tastes like cheese mustard.
The Burger.
It's a trip like you're,
you're eating it and you're like,
this is so strange.
It's like you're getting all these
different flavors and then you're like,
how quick does this cost cancer?
There's no this nothing even remotely
natural about that Shit.
Dude.
You know what I just saw on Reddit that
reminds me of is delicious.
God Damn.
I just on Reddit,
fight off the cancer.
It's worth it.
Take fucking cool ranch Doritos.
Someone took coherence Doritos and put
it into a salt grinder and the caption
was enjoy the rest of your life.
Everything.
Taste like.
That's a great idea.
Yeah.
It wasn't like a mortar and pestle.
Do it like alchemy and infinite core
ranch flavor on everything.
Wow.
That would be delicious on chicken or
something like that.
You know,
like if you fried chicken,
chicken breast with cool instead of
breadcrumbs,
you put cool ranch potato chips all over
the outside of it would be good on
anything.
That's so yummy.
That sounds really good on a Turd.
No,
it wouldn't.
But man,
this thing about stick,
this gets into metaphysics and this gets
into a place that I think about all the
time,
which is how much of what human beings
day to day that people are doing is just
is a stick in the same way that comics
have this thing.
How many times do you run into someone
who's got this thing going on,
which is their personality,
their ego,
this thing that they're clinging to her
putting out front that he isn't even
them at all.
Well,
how many people do that in the guise of
a radio personality?
I mean,
isn't that like the ultimate goof?
The radio personality?
I was listening to Opie and Anthony
today and they do a thing called October
where they go after hacky radio people
and they start talking like them and
mocking their act.
It's that.
It's the Strip club Dj the same.
That's the,
that's the thing,
they go into the,
hey ladies,
$15.
Kamikaze is coming up to the stage.
Girls drink for free guy ladies night
and then the president.
Yeah,
very much so.
When you speak in front of great groups
of people,
you must take on a different inflection.
We as a nation,
you can't just talk to them.
This is what I think we need to do.
I think this country is crazy.
We got to change some shit.
What are you saying?
You're not presidential.
Yeah,
you could say the same thing in a normal
way and it would seem really fucking
weird what my opponent thinks.
You know what?
My not my opponent just thinks that the
taxes are too high and I disagree.
It does not concern me.
What concerns me is the good will of the
American people.
What concerns me is the prosperity of
the American nation.
I just want people to be nicer to each
other and make more money.
What concerns me is seeing more made in
America.
Stickers on goods.
Yeah.
That was that voice,
that hypnotic fucking voice,
and then we allow it,
but keep bringing that down.
Like there's personality types,
you know,
this is where you get into like certain
personality types where you'll run into
specific groups of people who all act
exactly the same.
Like goths.
People were under certain band.
They all act.
They all,
they all share the similar personality
and in colts it's a,
a,
one of this.
One of the aspects of culture is that
everyone in the colt kind of acts the
same way and the way they're acting like
is like the leader,
you know.
So it gets really interesting when you
start considering to yourself how much
of what I'm doing is a shtick or how
much of what I'm doing is just imitated
from someone else,
whether it's.
My parents were good.
Excellent sense.
Exactly.
We,
we inflect on words.
You know,
I didn't even realize how heavy my
Boston accent was until I started seeing
myself on television.
I saw myself on television when I was 19
after taekwondo tournament.
I heard my accent.
I was like,
oh my God.
Oh God,
I got to stop that and I've slowly like
removed it over the.
But you have to hear it.
You have to hear it to realize you're
even saying it.
Yeah,
it's fucking crazy man.
And,
and,
and it's just amplitude tutor
atmosphere.
It's fun to like chase that thing back
and to.
This is where psychedelics are really
useful is because you begin to start
contemplating will,
who is behind all this?
Who's behind the accent?
Who's.
Do you ever just think,
where do my words come from?
I think
all cool motherfuckers that other people
copied,
you know,
that's where the accent is mean.
There must've been one cool motherfucker
in Kentucky that just knew how to talk
in a way that it just saying bad ass.
This mother fucker didn't,
didn't give a fuck.
You know what I'm saying?
He just sat there with a cigarette
dangling and have average miles.
I don't give a fuck.
And everybody in the neighborhood is
like,
man,
I want to be like that dude.
Yeah,
sure.
And they,
they all just sort of took on that
fluxion.
Well remember when a movie would come
out when you were an alum.
Actually,
that's not true.
It's not like one guy is not a patient
zero when it comes to accents,
you know,
it's some kind of collaborative
collaboration between groups of cool
people.
Sure.
But you know,
when a movie would come out and you
would be an elementary school and then
some catchphrase from that movie would
suddenly go rushing through elementary
school again.
I'm Rick James.
Bitch.
Yes,
yes,
exactly.
Where it just kind of like a wildfire
goes through idiots and they just
imitate and imitate and imitate the
can't help it.
They can't help it.
And,
and this,
this is the big question.
This is like,
but it's also fun.
Oh,
it's A.
Oh yeah,
it's huge.
It's human.
I mean,
God damn everyone's guilty of it,
man.
James,
there's no way to avoid it.
I love saying that.
No,
it's.
It seems to be up.
There seems to be a prevalence of people
saying boo right now.
Boom.
And also you started some shit,
man.
You've started powerful,
powerful,
beautiful.
I get powerful tweets.
Don't complain about that.
You can't worry too much.
I'm not complaining about it.
Enjoy shit like power.
I'm not complaining,
but I think it's great,
but I'm saying it's interesting to see
how certain behavior just micro bay
micro behaviors get imitated and echoed
throughout society.
It's a very interesting.
It is fascinating.
It is.
It's,
it's,
it's very interesting.
It's very interesting that we sort of
amalgamate.
We've sort of taken from all all sorts
of different sources around us that we
like all the different things that we
like.
It's always a problem with comics as
well.
You know,
we see a certain comics that are like
just doing Doug Stan hope you know.
How many guys have you seen that we're
opening for Doug?
Have you ever went to one at dog shows,
but years ago especially,
he would have guys open forum and they
were essentially doing stanhope and also
Jesus Christ.
You got you got you before you,
you know,
this is ridiculous.
It's super common.
There was a million have tells for
awhile.
We're just huge fans of a towel and they
couldn't even help it.
They started talking
day.
They just found themselves doing it,
you know,
you don't even realize it.
It's fucking incredible man,
and it's like you get thumped printed by
a reality in that way and it's goes way
back.
I mean that's the,
that's.
I just had my mom is a shrink on the
podcast and like she was talking about
the effect that she thinks.
What happens when you were a kid,
like getting your Dick snipped off,
like you were saying,
has on the rest of your life.
It has a huge effect.
You get some printed by your parents,
by the subjective Dna of your parents,
get them printed into you and then you
spend the rest of your life in this kind
of strange hypnotic trance not knowing
why you're doing what you're doing.
And that I think is the beginning of,
you know,
when you're talking about dumb dumb
people or people live or absorbed into
some religious structure.
I think the beginning of human ness
starts when you start thinking about,
wait,
what am I really?
What's behind this fucking mask?
What's behind the behavior mechanisms
that I picked up from my folks are from
movies or from influential friends or
from whatever.
What's the being residing behind all
that shit and that I think is when you
stop being a machine or start waking up
a little bit,
but until then you might as well be a
fucking brain and it God damn commodore
64.
Yeah.
Or You just enjoy this fucking weird
existence and marvel at all the mystery
of it all and just sort of try to take
it in and just enjoy it.
Because if you,
if you try to like get down to your core
all day,
every day you're going to,
you're going to miss what's,
what's enjoyable about the experience.
I don't necessarily know if we're ever
going to figure out what's motivating
us,
pushing us in one way or another.
What?
Why do you,
why do you talk the way you talk?
You know,
who are you?
But I,
but I do love the fact that there's so
many variables.
I do love a guy like Joey Diaz.
I do love how Ra is so much different
than Joey.
Brian.
So much different than me.
We're all just weird,
you know,
personalities that have come about
through a whole bunch of different
scenarios,
a bunch of different ways to live a
life,
you know,
and different locations and different
problems and challenges and different
genetics.
It's a fucking trip,
man.
The human experience to get to from
point a to Duncan trussell at 37 years
old is a wild,
crazy fuck load and everyone's road is,
is unique and different and and creates
a different result.
Have you heard the term dependent
origination?
No.
It's a Buddhist term and the term is
that there is nothing independent.
There's nothing independent of it.
There's no,
no thing that isn't related to some
other thing in the universe which
creates this kind of tapestry.
So makes sense.
So the example that you know,
of course beer,
this beer bottle is not by itself,
it comes from sand.
It's just what you're seeing here is in
the flow of time that a temporary form
that a bunch of sand and paper,
which comes from trees his congealed
into to form this thing,
but 700 years from now,
this fucking thing is going to be sand
again.
You said what you're watching right now
is just a moment of this thing's true
existence and in in in the same way you
and Joey Diaz and Brian and me and
everyone listening to this,
or just one mode,
one moment of beingness in this web that
for us traces all the way back
apparently to nuclear fusion inside of
stars,
which has gone through infinite time
until it's finally manifested in the
form of whatever the parts.
Yeah,
exactly.
Which for a moment in time,
for a moment in time,
that little bit of the tab tonight at
10:30
sold out.
Bitch.
That's cool.
Yeah.
It's.
It's a an amazing connection that we
have to everything that's ever existed
and we are part of some weird infinite
cycle as as the planet,
as,
as the star that heats the planet.
All of these will end.
The universe won't,
it's this is,
but a blip,
even the life of a star is,
but a blip in the in the life of the
universe and they blow up all the time.
They said that there was a beautiful
show on a hyper novas there were talking
about when they first started detecting
gamma ray bursts in the galaxy.
They didn't know what was going on.
They thought it was possible that we
were under attack by an alien race
because there was a huge burst of energy
that were were happening all over the
space,
all,
all throughout the universe,
so they thought it was possible.
They were were actually alien wars at
one point in time.
That was something that was being
considered until they understand the
mechanism or understood rather than
mechanism.
Behind Novus,
they're happening all the time.
They just.
They're just blowing out.
There's Mooney and stars.
We can't even.
Yeah.
You gotta go.
If in your lifetime to the Keck
observatory in Hawaii,
if you've never been there,
it's one of the,
one of the highest observatories and
it's above the clouds.
It's really wild because you're driving,
you drive.
It's on the big island and you drive is
a long ass drive.
It's like a two hour drive up the
mountain and as you're driving you hit
clouds and you're like,
fuck man,
we're not going to be able to see shit.
We took this big drive up here,
but we're not going to able to see shit
because was all these clouds.
Then you drive past the clouds and you
get up there and you go,
oh my God.
Because first of all,
you're at 13,000
feet and second of all there's no light
pollution on the island.
They have these diffusers on all these
lamps,
so when you look at you don't even have
to look through a telescope.
Dude,
you just look up when you're at the
observatory and you're like,
oh my God.
The milky ways and staying.
Yeah,
and it makes you so angry that you can't
see that every day.
Yeah.
Like if we didn't have these greedy ass
fucking cities with lights everywhere
and driving around with headlights,
it would like if we could have just for
one hour or couple hours of one day,
well maybe just one night a year where
everyone shots all the power off for
three hours and we all from six to 9:00
PM central.
Remember tonight is star appreciation
night.
We all shut out all the powers in
cities.
Yeah,
they,
they've tried that a few times where
I'll look it up.
Oh yeah.
Good.
Good idea.
See I'm behind the times somebody
thought it up,
but if we did that and you,
you,
you could see that we would have so many
people that would be so much more in awe
of space and so much more interested in
the.
And especially children interested in
the idea of pursuing astronomy or are
pursuing rocketry or working for NASA or
something.
I mean,
just the,
our appreciation for,
you know,
funding things like NASA and the Hubble
telescope and new telescopes and you
know,
the Keck observatory and all these,
you know,
all that stuff would be so much more
appreciated if we could see the majesty
of the stars.
We've robbed ourselves from that,
of that with cities,
the,
the light.
We don't even realize it because we've
grown up with these things,
but all that light all the time has
robbed us of really the most amazing
thing you could ever see.
And one of the most humbling things I've
ever seen in my life.
I've had psychedelic experiences that
didn't affect me as much as looking at
those stars because I,
I remember that night I couldn't sleep.
I remember I got back to the hotel room.
I was just lying in bed staring up at
the ceiling,
thinking how insane that thing was and
that that's up there all the time that I
can't see it.
And it really hit home.
The feeling that was when I really
started pushing the idea of the planet
as an organic spaceship.
That's when I really started talking
about it.
That's when I came up with that whole
bit about,
you know,
explaining the,
the war on Iraq,
hurling through the universal,
how insane it is to pay attention to the
Grand Canyon.
You know,
that that bit it was like,
there's people out there look deep at
Grand Canyon.
Meanwhile,
above you is infinity.
Did you see the Graham Hancock video
that he posted on his information
website of the sound of the Earth space?
Did I got the dolphins do.
It's the radio waves radio waves that
the,
uh,
the radiation belts.
Yeah.
But it sounds a lot.
Sounds like,
sounds like dolphins.
It sounds like chirping Wales Brion.
Pull that up because it's fucking
trippy.
Are you drinking a rockstar?
You fucking Rockstar?
Yeah.
By the way,
it was,
it's called a earth hour.
It's actually one hour a year that
everyone's supposed to do.
I just turn off all their power except
for the refrigerator for an hour.
Really?
Yeah.
That's.
La doesn't do that shit.
Fuck you gotta do coke.
What was the shit you want me to look
at?
Seven Hancock site.
He's got this newsletter.
I don't know the exact,
it's just I'm just look up scientists
find the sound of the earth.
Yeah.
It'll pop up right away.
It sounds like Chirping Josh or Wales.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and it's a apparently the sound of the
radio show,
the radiation belts and make a sound
that's like it wavers.
Yeah.
We're weird,
man.
I think it's just a matter of time
before we.
We get contacted by something that's
more intelligent than us.
I've been thinking that more and more
lately.
I think if there is something out there
that's more intelligent than than than
human beings,
it's going to have to contact us really
soon because we're like real
close.
Well,
this is the thing,
man.
This is.
I can't remember if fucking said that's
one of the singularity people said
humankind's first contact with an
extraterrestrial or with rather an alien
intelligence is going to be a machine
that's woken up and that's going to be
our first experience with it is
something we made
instead of instead of a thing from
space.
Well,
it's possible.
It's possible.
It is possible that we're at the height.
I mean,
there was one,
a recent Harvard astronomer that decided
after looking at 500 different stars
that we may be the only thing out there
and that there's so little a life or
evidence of life in these.
These planets is 500 different planets
rather than they've observed,
but I think that's ridiculous.
The most ridiculous because he is coming
from a planet that has life.
That's one of those 500.
So it's not that there's nothing in 500.
No.
You found one dummy and you're on it.
There's one and you found $500 that
don't.
But you find one that does.
Okay.
You have to add that in stupid.
You don't just go looking for another
one and if the other one you can't find
it.
Well they don't exist.
Meanwhile you are one that doesn't make
any sense.
And also man,
that creek bed and Mars,
that shit gives me goosebumps when I see
pictures of the fucking gravel and Mars
from water flowing on Mars.
I just think about what that must have
looked like on that planet with Martian
water rolling through whatever it was
rolling through.
I think there was probably life on Mars.
Yeah.
Brian,
pull up how earth sounds from space on
youtube and uh,
and it's,
it will freak you.
It's fucking loud ass people interfering
with our podcast yelling in the street.
But we got.
We got no sound proofing here at the
icehouse.
How earth our earth sounds from space.
It's on youtube.
It's so it shows up the earth itself.
You see like cloud formations and shit.
No,
that's not the one.
That's not the most recent one.
Let me see.
Let me look up Graham Hancock.com.
How was that movie you saw last night?
Joe?
Fucking awesome.
What is this?
A looper oh good.
I'm glad.
That's good.
Oh my God.
Is it good?
It's not just good.
It's like one of the best movies I think
I've ever seen.
It was a really good fucking moving.
I can't find the sound man.
I don't know where it is.
Anyway,
go find it folks.
It's on my twitter.
Why don't I just look on my own fucking
twitter.
Stupid ass.
I'm so dumb.
I'm
the,
uh,
the looper movies.
Really fucking good.
It's really good.
Writing,
you know,
I didn't know anything about it.
Which one of those mind benders where
your brain feels like it's getting
stretched out because it's so.
No,
you know,
it wasn't.
That was the thing they managed to,
to avoid.
They managed to avoid all sorts of.
You go to my um,
my twitter.
Brian,
I found it.
If you pull up a,
there's a
tweet I retweeted a gentleman named
Aaron Rodriguez.
Congratulations.
You were the guy who gets mentioned on a
podcast,
Aaron Rodriguez and it says apparently
the van Allen Radiation Belt sings like
a whale.
Nothing to fear guys.
And it's a 22 hours.
Okay.
I retweeted it.
So find that Sun Sun.
Um,
what was I saying
you were talking about.
I don't know what you're talking about
before that man fucking lost me.
There it is.
Yeah.
That's a planet.
That's so creepy.
Sounds like it's calling a dog.
You know what it's calling other planets
saying this place is filled with a bunch
of crickets and cons with nuclear bombs.
Don't fuck with it.
Is the end of it.
I don't think that fucking thing.
That thing does not sound that.
That does not sound like a defenseless
thing.
To me.
That sounds like a thing that could just
jump out of the woods and bite your head
off.
Well,
that's not a real sound.
You know,
it's radio waves,
so we've sort of interpreted them as a
sound as I understand it.
I don't think it's actually that you
stuck your head out of the space
shuttle.
You wouldn't hear that.
Yeah.
To get wiped off.
You probably would hear that accent.
Yeah.
You wouldn't hear shit.
Your head would freeze instantly.
Isn't that crazy that you would just
freeze instantly in space?
Yeah.
You just couldn't live.
Is there someone at the door?
Who is it?
Who is.
Who's motherfuckers keep interrupting.
I think what I think is our show,
a comedy show starts in 30 minutes,
so it's probably comics,
but comics or would just come back here
and not say anything.
Hold on.
Woo Dunkin.
Yes.
Brian,
how are you doing?
Where are you?
Where are you at next?
Where are you going out town?
I'm going to Vancouver this weekend.
Oh,
lucky people are playing at that hotel
comedy club.
What's it called again?
The comedy Max.
Oh,
that's awesome.
I knew it was because joe is a type of
guy that just tries doors.
He doesn't knock doors unlocked house.
They stealthy keep it on the download
cock sucker.
So this.
It's an audio rendering of radio waves.
That's what it is.
Captured by probes.
Still fucking weird.
Lock that door to keep out the stockers
or something going on,
buddy.
Know Me.
Dog hit on me.
Keeping a beautiful.
Did you lock it up man?
We're here for another soul down show
tonight at the Ice House in Pasadena.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
will we sling comedy Dick on a regular
basis and you know,
we got a lot of people come back so we
could try to come up with as much new
shit as possible.
And uh,
I'm going to be doing a lot on the earth
thing and like a whale.
That's my new barrier.
No,
I don't think there's any material doing
a whole chunk on snm tonight.
Are you really?
I can't wait to hear it better.
Not use any of my stories.
You fuck what?
As an m story do you?
I know I got all those fucking things.
You have no ball gag stories and that's
a shame.
No,
I operate on a different level of you.
I don't know if I don't have the right
level.
I'm not saying it is,
but it just saying it's different labs,
different level.
You're into your insistence.
Shit.
Let's say on occasion.
I'm not just some shit that makes me
uncomfortable as a man.
Afraid to experiment by what he's.
He's judging me because I'm tying to all
gag into a lady and you diaper never did
that.
You made that up.
No judge you Duncan.
I would never judge you.
You.
I love you exactly the way you are.
I don't want you to change even
slightly,
but the ball gag thing bothers me.
Bothers me.
It's totally normal.
Like the first time I'm like,
well,
I'm still intrigued by this ball.
Gag Business.
Let me try it again.
Joey,
sit in with us,
man.
What are you doing?
You what?
Okay.
See,
I'm gonna Joey Diaz.
Ladies,
gentlemen in and out.
He's here.
He's gone.
He's here for
a sold out show,
the Basil Dino,
welcome to my radio voice duty to do so.
Opie Anthony attack these guys on what
they called Shocktober.
They do it every year apparently.
Fucking so funny because it was opie and
Anthony.
It was um,
who else was on Tom?
Papa was in there.
I'm just saying.
I don't know.
It was just,
you know,
the show is always like a bunch of
people like all in together
and it was really fucking funny.
And then within a half an hour,
an hour of them doing it,
the radio station took to their facebook
page because the ONA savages had started
attacking the facebook page and shitting
all over it,
bananas and sell them.
They're all drowned in a.
it's just so funny.
Oh,
I mean,
I just,
I just fucking love that.
They're so sensitive.
They took it on their facebook page.
Look,
this is what happened.
You got,
you got goofed on.
You should have been moved on a long
time ago and then you would have never
done that radio voice.
I think they train in that voice.
I think that that there's schools where
people trained to talk like that and you
just choose like strip club or or radio
voice or whether person
it was saying anthony was saying that
they made them.
It was anthony or opening.
I forget.
I think they're all talking about how
the guy actually said,
I want you to visualize who your
audience is.
Just,
you know,
take a picture out of a magazine that
represents that guy.
You know,
you're a blue collar guy and just put
that up there on the wall and you know,
that's the guy you're talking to.
That's your guy.
You know what Anthony was saying that he
put up John Casey.
It was fucking funny,
but it's like that.
That happens whenever you get a producer
involved in,
in someone who's in a non creative
person involved in trying to shape your
radio personality.
Look,
gonna do man is just tighten up your
image.
You need a thumb ring and you thought
about a new nose rings.
Yeah man.
Thumb rings to Anthony Bourdain is the
only guy that I've ever met that used to
wear a thumb ring.
This douche bag.
Cool guy and he has a thumb ring and I'd
watch them on the show and I'm like,
man,
I just kind of talked to them about that
ring.
We're going to be fine or toe rings.
Get the fuck Outta here.
And the tattoo around the belly button.
That's another one.
Just get bored.
I can see tattoo on your belly button.
That's just a board issue but not a toe
ring.
Did you see that shit on Reddit?
The guy who had it rem job tattooed on
his face like right on his mouth,
on his mustache.
Really,
it's the saddest thing.
It looks like he's been crying like him
and some other guy.
They're both obviously fucked up and one
of them as some shit tattoo on his
forehead,
but the other guys,
right
rim job.
I think there's a lot of people that
just incredibly self destructive.
What is that?
Is that.
Is that like us losing our natural
reward system with hunter and gathering
and being stuck into some weird fucking
environment.
We're taking pills and trying to
overcome reality with pharmaceutical
drugs and sedate our sell through shit
jobs and boring,
meaningless existences as a cog in the
wheel and then you just go crazy
substance abuse,
see your face.
They.
It's like the human version of pigs in
slaughterhouses that start chewing off
their own legs because they're too close
to each other.
You just end up going into some,
but also a lot of times when people do
that shit outside of the guy who did rim
job,
a lot of times when people fuck up their
body,
they're doing it because they want
specific types of girls to like them.
I think.
I think that they're writing rim job
when you're not that I said except for
that guy,
but like the people who like just
fucking like putting the hang themselves
from their nipples are like people who
do the earrings,
the big ear holes.
If you stand there looking for certain
types of girls.
I think that's what it is.
I think it's amazing pattern.
Some of it for sure it hits the ear
thing is.
I would have never saw that coming me
either.
I met a lot of cool people that have it
too and I don't want to judge them.
I don't want to judge them,
but that's a fucking a trippy thing.
You gotTa fucking toilet paper roll in
your ear,
son.
Did you see that prank or maybe it was
just.
It was an idea for a prank.
It's awful,
but it's like you sneak up on one of
those guys with a lock and put it in the
ear hole and lock it so they've got a
lock like locked into their ear.
I think I saw a video of it or someone
suggesting someone do that.
Brutal.
That's horrific because then you'd have
to get it clipped.
That's terrific.
It's a dangerous thing,
man.
It's not a strategic thing to have giant
holes in your ears.
It's dangerous.
Yeah.
What if.
What if you ripped it off and then beat
the guy to death with it?
Yeah.
You do that too.
Well,
you would deserve it.
Probably.
It's a shitty move.
Yeah.
Locking someone,
putting a lock in someone's fucking
hear.
You better know that combination.
Bitch.
That's a rude prank.
It's not,
I guess pranks,
the wrong word.
It's an assault and attack,
but yeah,
all that shit.
Body modification,
that thing where uh,
people in Korea,
is it Korea that they're putting up
donuts in their heads,
head bagels.
What's going on?
It's like we're sick of our bodies or
something,
man.
We're taking these strange paths to make
our bodies look different.
It's really fucking weird.
And The lady just grew an ear off or
arm,
but that wasn't cosmetic.
That's because she had to.
She had cancer.
Yeah.
That's not related,
but yeah,
there is a lot of weird shit that people
do.
But I say that,
but then I have two sleeves of tattoos.
You know,
two arms are covered in drawing.
Yeah,
right.
But still again talk.
No,
I think two sleeves of tattoos is a fuck
load cooler than having your head and
flavor.
Yeah,
it's cooler,
but it's still weird to,
you know,
the average person doesn't want to sit
there and have someone drawn them with a
fucking scratching needle shows inc
under their skin.
Just to make it look cool.
I want a fucking tattoo.
What'd you get?
I don't know.
That's the problem,
man.
It's torture me for my whole life.
I'm always thinking about what it would
be and I don't know.
I'm hoping that when I,
when I go out to Brazil and slurp back
some Iowasca,
it'll come to me.
I think it was just a little nervous,
a little sweet face on your arm.
Little Hobo with a giant Dick like evil
boy that has tattooed on from a dmt
word.
Huge Dick.
But little hobos face.
No,
no,
I don't like that Tattoo.
I was going to any
big veiny giants like that Tattoo.
How about a black dude?
Nope.
Dick to represent the American Indian
being speaking my language now.
It means big,
hard red deck like the hawk.
If he was red,
now you feel me on this?
Nothing.
Damn.
It goes on a good path.
What would you.
What about some of the from the Bhagavad
Gita as or like a,
but again,
like that should all seem so fucking
like contrived,
you know,
it seems because like,
I don't,
I'm not,
I'm not going to like look at my arm.
You're like,
no.
How about Alistair Crowley?
On your shoulder that man,
I haven't.
Alistair Crawley poster and shit falls
off my walls.
I don't want my body some,
some goddamn chaos.
There's chaos.
Magician named freighter is low if he
doesn't care.
I said his name,
who mails me like really weird.
Oh,
a cult shit man.
Like really strange.
Like um,
he just sent me a demon,
a demon summoning box where he's painted
the front of it.
It sounds really dumb when I came in.
So many books.
There's a anyway,
there's a lot of weird.
There's a lot of strange shit out there
man.
But the point is I would never want
curly tattooed on my body.
There's a lot of people that have
terence Mckenna tattooed on them for the
interesting.
I think that's pretty good,
but I don't know man.
I like more of a,
something that's less specific,
you know,
something that may be as
the Terence Mckenna Tattoo going to be
real problematic if December 20,
first 2012 rolls over another that
happens.
Although he wasn't really convinced that
anything
was going to happen.
Well everyone's Scott.
That.
I mean there's a simple out for 2012,
which is that it's a shift in the
vibration.
Well,
no one's ever predicted anything ever.
That's my problem with it.
No one's ever correctly predicted any
like huge change in the world ever.
No one's ever said on this day to
specifically to the day the world will.
The world will change forever.
They tried with y two k?
Yes.
Oh God.
That was crazy.
I wonder if they traveled with.
I wonder if people thought 1984 was
going to be a big year because of the
book.
Man.
I remember.
Do you remember?
I don't remember that.
Well,
1984 is like nothing compared to what's
really going on right now.
And your fucking phone is a wireless gps
tracker that they can turn on and
listened to you and record you talking
anymore.
You are?
Yeah.
That shit.
We are so primitive back then,
man.
Your phone plug into the wall.
Well,
it's really interesting when you go back
to like the 18 hundreds,
you know,
like when was the war of the worlds
weren't written.
I believe it was written in the 18
hundreds,
right?
Came on the radio.
People start radios.
Teen Twenties or thirties of the word.
I'll say 19.
Twenty three.
One was went home.
Boy did it on the radio.
Orson wells.
What year was that?
It was hg wells.
Eighteen 98.
Oh Damn.
Yeah.
And then uh,
Orson Welles did it.
I think in the 19.
The early 19 hundreds.
Hey,
powerful.
Ian Edwards is here.
Ladies.
Gentlemen,
what's up brother?
See Him as a man.
How you doing?
Come on in target.
I'm comics started shuffling lays
gentleman,
which means which we will.
We're going to shift from this to that.
Yeah.
Let's share the shift from the Duncan
trussell family hour podcast explosion
in your mouth to a nice house
chronicles.
So that sounds good,
Brian.
Oh,
I don't know what you're doing that.
Do you want to do one?
Not really.
Don't have to.
Okay,
then we won't do it.
All right folks.
No more fucking podcast.
Well,
we got.
Well it's not even 10:00
though,
Dude.
Let's keep going then.
If we're not going to do a nice house
chronicle.
So let's keep going because it's only,
it's only a quarter to 10 shows at
10:30,
but to have a sold out show here tonight
at the Ice House,
Ian Edwards,
ready to get your freak on.
What do you,
what about this,
this shit with,
uh,
the dispensary's now that it got
overturned,
what happened?
I think they decided to let them keep
continuing to operate because they need
the tax revenue.
It would be catastrophic to a lot of
these neighborhoods if all of a sudden
those businesses pulled out.
What people don't understand is that
this,
these businesses,
these cannabis dispensaries have become
a big part of the economic success of a
lot of communities mean not only do
people work there and have jobs and get
paid,
but they also pay rental landlords.
I mean,
there's a lot of them.
There's hundreds of them that would mean
that hundreds of places no longer have
someone renting them.
And it's not like there's a shortage of,
uh,
of,
of places to rent.
There's a lot of places to rent.
So if you,
you know,
it's like commercial real estate.
Like I had a look around at a lot of
commercial places to get a podcast
studio,
looked at a lot of office space and
stuff like that.
It's fucking everywhere.
Everywhere.
It's so many places are available and
open and if they decided just randomly
to shut down 700 different fucking
dispensary's for just dubious reasons.
For reasons that don't make any sense at
all,
it would be.
It would.
It would suck.
It would fuck up.
The economy is a lot of money that goes
to paying taxes.
Joe,
is it.
Was that.
I also read that the IDA was saying that
they're gonna stop rating medicinal
marijuana dispensary.
No,
I didn't read that.
When did they say that?
See someone.
I don't know if it's true.
I think it might have.
It might be with
you.
Probably would because one of the things
that I read is that the dea,
they won't disclose any information
about bus and what they're doing is
they're going in and rating people.
They're taking all the marijuana,
they're taking their money,
taking their plants.
They confiscate all the records.
They write down everyone's name and then
they do nothing and they don't have to
do anything and when you try to find
information in the case,
they just say an ongoing investigation
and they don't do anything,
so there's been a or doing something but
they ain't really doing nothing.
They're coming in and jacking people and
not arresting anybody.
And Todd Mccormick was the first person
who told me about this and I was like,
that doesn't even make sense.
I was like,
am I missing something in the story?
And then I went and looked at it online,
but no,
that is the practice.
The practice is they just make it
ridiculous for these people to try to
run a business and they'd come in and
take all their shit.
Like trying to act like they're doing
something to kind of keep the show going
that they're doing their job but they
don't really want to arrest.
They probably agree with the states that
have California that have weed laws,
but there's like,
all right,
we got to do something so let's just
shut this down.
But not really try people.
I don't know if it's an agreement thing
because a lot of cops do not like weed.
You know what I mean?
When when cops break into guys' houses
and shoot their dog 17 fucking times and
look around and find a pipe,
a little bit of weed on it.
Have you seen some of those videos and
the links?
I can't.
Trendous man.
They shot some former marine 17 times
the other day and they thought this guy
had pot him.
He had nothing.
It's the whole thing is crazy.
I thought he was a dealer.
There's no pot in the house.
When are you going to put some of these
cops away just to let other cops know.
It's always like,
let's not rush to judgment that police
chief is like,
let's not rush to judgment.
Let's see what happens.
But they rushed to judgment when the
cops right up a criminal forum and
somebody that they arrest and they put
the story on the news,
like instantly that person's guilty,
but when a cop shoots somebody lists
this weight.
Well,
sometimes they do that,
but you know,
the Internet is sort of taking a lot of
that away.
They're exposing these people like that.
That officer at Uc Davis,
that's pepper sprayed those kids in the
face and then there was a recent
situation where the cop cold cocked a
chick at a Puerto Rican day,
pride for it and he thought that she did
something,
but she didn't.
She just was in the wrong place,
the wrong time.
So he turns around and cracks her.
It was fucked up,
man.
It's fucked up to watch that guy's in
trouble.
That guy's in trouble be.
Yeah,
he fucking shed vein.
Even if she did throw water on them,
you're not allowed to punch her.
Dude.
You're a cop.
Girl throws water.
You can't punch her in the face.
A little more restricted.
The cool thing about the proliferation
of fucking cameras everywhere,
like it goes both ways,
but I've heard that the TSA is not
letting you film them anymore.
If you heard this.
I've heard that.
Yeah.
That's when we had a WHO's telling us a
story?
Kevin Prayer was telling us the story of
being stuck at the airport and trying to
film and his girlfriend trying to film
it and they wouldn't let him.
They took him into a room and it's like,
I don't have a witness here anymore.
At least out there.
I have a witness like I want to film
this.
They wouldn't let him.
The whole thing is,
it's just ridiculous.
Solaris the TSA.
I can like cops now.
Police State,
Ladies and gentlemen,
we've reached a police state.
People want to control people.
The system sucks.
The systems a mass.
People are complaining and then they
want to control the people complaining
so they want to tighten down a police
state instead of addressing what the
people are complaining about when people
to the point where they're rioting in
the streets or there's an occupy Wall
Street type of movement.
Man.
The fact that the government does not
address that on a formal basis,
on a regular basis,
that they're not doing something about
that and adjusting.
It just shows you how,
how much content they have for the
actual people and who they really work
for.
That's not even a subject of a guarantee
that shit's going to come up in the
debates.
You think they're going to talk about
occupy Wall Street and addressing their
demands
or the petro dollar or the or the fact
that China is like apparently switching
away from the dollar to buy oil.
Have you heard about that shit?
No,
I don't blame him.
If they're seen the value of the dollar.
Jesus doesn't even meet.
This spooky thing is apparently our
entire currency is based on the fact
that most people use it to buy oil and
so they have to have vast reserves of it
on hand to buy the oil,
but if that changes,
then our dollar will drop even more than
it's valued at now and the most extreme
way because it's not based on gold until
a lot of people.
It's called the petro dollar theory.
It's on wikipedia.
It's a theory,
but the theory is that all the wars that
we've been in have been with places that
we're about to switch the currency from
the dollar to something else,
and whenever that happens we go in and
attack because that's the only thing
that our dollars valued on.
But it's a theory.
It's a conspiracy about while we
attacked Iraq.
Yes,
and right after we had,
because he had already switched over and
we attacked Iraq and then we turned it
back to the dollar.
Within a year of attacking.
Yeah.
Little while you'll hear them talk about
that in the fucking debates.
You won't hear that come up.
Well,
you won't hear them talking about Wiki
leaks.
So there was a purpose to all these
wars.
That's good to know that they're not
doing it for nothing.
That's good money,
son.
You're not going to hear anybody talking
about Wiki leaks and the debate and that
shit ain't going to sweep that under the
rug.
Is that dude still hold up in that has
been there for months to get him any
pussy.
You should.
They should sneak him in some hippie
plus.
You have to pay rent there.
It's a good question.
I wonder if he's got a dope suite too.
He just promises not to leak anything
about them.
Yeah.
I wonder if he has to promise.
Oh Shit.
He probably has some serious shit on
that guy.
Well,
it's weird that
they're in there in England,
but it's the Ecuadorian embassy,
so he's allowed to stay.
Even though he's in England,
they all just stand around waiting for
him to come out.
So he stays in that house for months.
He's been in that house for months
now.
He comes out and does little speeches
from that balcony,
but he's still in the house.
Technically I was calling him Ray Ponzel
rape rape.
Well they,
they,
uh,
they already got that.
The DNA test back on the condom and it
shows none of his deal.
Yeah.
I don't think,
you know,
they just want to get.
I'm sorry Julian.
I love you.
Yeah,
they're jacking that guy.
It's really scary,
isn't it?
Yeah.
It's fucking scary.
And also that other guy that's in just
in some pod somewhere getting hose 24
hours a day,
they have him in solitary confinement.
He's naked.
He's not allowed to wear clothes.
He just like balled up in a fetal
position in some orange room.
Getting sprayed with water.
I was is every few hours.
Music?
Yeah.
Is that what you heard?
I made up a lot of that when I went to
visit him.
That's how it was after I fucked up.
But he's not doing great.
I don't think he can send letters and
stuff.
I don't think you can do anything enough
letters,
you know,
saying essentially psychologically
torturing.
He's gone.
I bet he's gone.
When he comes out of there,
he's going to be a drooling boo Radley.
You won't know.
That's optimistic
when it comes out of they're never
coming out.
Coming out.
And what.
You know,
what's really interesting is this guy
could have done something far worse and
he would be in a real prison,
was interacting with people.
He could have been a murderer,
he could've been the DC sniper.
He could've been.
He could've done something far more
horrific and he would be interacting
with people with this guy did was leaked
some information about some shit that he
thought was horrific and in doing so
they're treating him like he is fucking
Lex Luthor to treating him like he's the
worst bad guy ever.
I.
While Manson's and a regular prison
somewhere,
Rogan.
Have you seen this list that leaked
about that?
Different signs that someone's a
terrorist like at week from the army or
something like what to look for?
What was one of them?
Everything you do like you like you are.
There's,
there's,
there's gradients on the list and on the
red side it's pretty much all of us.
All of us are like,
would be considered like terrorists by
this new thing.
Did you find it?
Oh,
if you use social media.
Yeah,
I read some.
I read some of it back in the day.
This podcast would probably be
considered like communists the mccarthy
era or you know,
just just some red party shit for sure.
Wow.
Here's some warning signs.
According to the U,
s military.
Wow.
You've recently changed your choices in
entertainment.
You have peculiar discussions have gone
to a blowjob porn.
You complain about bias to your socially
withdrawn.
Jody is jody,
is that on?
I don't hear him check their beautiful.
Um,
uh,
you're socially withdrawn.
You're frustrated with mainstream
ideologies.
Your risk factors for radicalization
include social networks and youth being
young on facebook because it,
you're a young urine terrorist.
That is fucking hilarious.
That is just like the most broad
sweeping brush I think I've ever read
ever in an official
think came out with this.
This is some cons.
I know.
I think it's like the army and,
and,
but the combination of this with the
indefinite detention act,
that's where shit gets creepy because
it's one thing to just be like,
yeah,
those are
signs that someone might be doing
something weird,
but then I think a terrorist,
someone suspected of terrorism can just
get arrested according to the indefinite
detention act without a trial.
So that's where she gets a little not,
not going to sleep that well at night.
Well,
we have this girl who's coming on the
podcast tomorrow,
Amber Lyon,
who was working for CNN and was like
clearly censored,
like they were told not to tell stories.
There are certain things that were told
not to cover.
There's certain areas where they wanted
to.
They wanted to report on actual news and
they were told not to and they were told
to read off government propaganda that
they knew was not true.
Yeah.
And this is on CNN,
so you know,
it's,
it's real.
It's on it.
It's not like.
It's not like people going,
oh yeah,
well they wouldn't act on that stuff.
No,
no,
no.
This is like,
like they've figured out a way to
control media and propaganda is a real
thing.
Now it's 100 percent real.
They can big and lie to you all day long
and if you want to travel anywhere,
they can restrict you.
They not only can they restrict you,
but just to travel.
You are going to have your body
magnetically scans so they can see you
fucking naked.
If you travel,
you must allow them to see your name.
Goodbye.
That doesn't work.
As Joey Diaz clearly explained
on the Alex Jones show,
they missed a bag of weed,
has hidden under
balls.
It can't see through Joey's balls.
They might be able to see distant
telescope.
They have not yet developed a scanner
machine that could see past better.
Watch that al Qaeda is going to cut
your.
To smuggle something to another country.
You have to buy Joe's Joe DSS,
sack skin.
What they need to do is this scientist
that clone Dolly the sheep.
They need to clone Joey's balls.
Just make them really large extent.
No coffee grounds.
Put them over stealth bombers and you
can just fucking flying in the x ray
machines wouldn't see shit.
We get you these x Ray.
They put that fucking umpire thing on
your chest.
That's what my skin on my nuts through.
It's like fucking shield.
It doesn't go through because I hide
that.
Sat behind them was all they could see
is this motherfucker got three nuts.
He's the luckiest motherfucker.
They don't want to gonna overlook the
morals.
They robbed the $800,000
worth of loot to TSA people.
Yeah.
They found the IPAD.
Did you see that?
But they robbing those motherfuckers
dog.
Yeah,
they definitely have the.
They're always like swiping watches and
shit.
You got to hear a lot of stories,
but I went through the tsa today and
they were being extra careful because
like a penny dropped off into the and
they're like,
sir,
your penny.
Don't forget your pen.
You're probably gonna.
Feel guilty.
Everybody's watching.
Everyone's watching you.
Just saying this is a metal washer.
Just watching the men in the metal,
but it doesn't go off.
Go right through the scanner machine.
It goes,
what?
You fucking.
Wouldn't it be hilarious?
They're not even checking you.
Definitely.
Would that be crazy?
Would that be if half those machines,
it really cost like $800 rich body go
through and they just make you go
through and press a button and go.
You're going through it and just
checking to see,
look how many fucking times they find
people with bullets and guns and fucking
stupidity.
It makes you really think it really
makes you fucking think.
I guarantee avenues people just
whatever,
just whatever.
You know today's a data free fucking
day.
You might want a bazooka.
We're not going to catch you.
Well,
they did some independent testing where
they tried to get people through and
they got through with a bunch of guys.
You'd be fucking surprised.
Well No,
it goes off a foil from Gum,
Huh?
Yeah.
When you have like a pack of Dentine
with a push through foil back.
That shit go.
You have that in your pocket.
You'll beat,
but you've got a weapon.
But meanwhile the metal that you're
watches made out for whatever fucking
reason,
that doesn't go off.
It just makes me want to puke when I
look over and see a fucking old man
today.
I saw an 80 year old man with a brace on
his neck getting like a hard core.
You know what?
Come on.
He was he white.
He probably did.
Did some shit back in the creepy shit.
Fuck it up to be alive.
Did some racist shit.
Needs to go search.
Say workers were working them over like
a water hose.
Help they dip their fingers inside.
Sanitizers stuck it right up his ass.
He had Sam took John Sanitizer,
hand sanitizer inside your ass.
That would not be cutting your asshole.
Yeah,
someone's done it.
Someone does it all day.
Someone's probably addicted to doing
that.
Going to a doctor.
I've got to stop putting her hand
sanitizer up my ass and is actually a
new thing.
A new fucking.
Remember we went to town and we had
dinner with some doctor.
I was there.
It's telling us about emergency room
share.
A friend of mine used to all that.
They in Chicago national that they
buried the fucking God member.
What were the stories about Josh
motherfuck?
You're John Rollo.
Tell you about his buddy.
The boxer who went for shoulder surgery
and before you have shoulder surgery,
they shoot a,
uh,
a thing in you and it and it fucking
freezes your arm.
Your nerves.
You can have your nerves like 18 months.
They shot the motherfucking the wrong
arm.
Oh No.
Yeah.
Boxer as John Rollo.
He picked somebody,
Andre Ward to a decision or something
like that a couple of years ago.
And then they did the surgery.
They shot this motherfucker in the wrong
order,
but it takes 18 months to heal because I
guess it's one centimeter of fucking
month that heels backwards.
John was telling me,
Oh,
can you man?
They go in for surgery to take out your
wrong.
Fuck.
I boss,
boss ruin has a nerve issue that he had
a nerves fucked up and it was over a
year where his arm hadn't healed yet.
Something we.
Your nerves take time,
dude.
I've heard of people bringing their dogs
into the vet to get him groomed and they
put them to sleep because of confusion.
They get it confused.
Yeah.
Will Ferrell's tats.
Oh Shit.
That's a call back from an old Joe Rogan
podcast.
Will Ferrell.
Is Cats feral cats.
Oh,
remember that going back to the ems,
a friend of mine out there,
he was a comic and use will be,
you know,
used to work in the ambulance and Queens
and uh,
like people would come in with shit
stuck in they ass.
Like one guy had that Gi joe doll.
It was,
he was talking about people getting
stood up.
Graham,
Steve Graham always talks about that
when he did his residency in Miami,
said they found light bulbs up people's
assets.
Those those twisty light bulbs or the
twisty joints have led light bulbs up
their assets and then the light bulb
broke some of the thing.
He said,
well,
this dude's stuck.
A Gi Joe.
Joe Doll up his ass,
but he couldn't pull it out because the
arms opened up.
That's when you have to call the bar.
And he was like,
Hook Dude.
This guy,
the doctor,
we were talking at two at dinner.
He said something that I'd never heard
before,
which is some people were taking nitrous
oxide,
remember this and inflating their
testicles with it and that some people
do that.
A guy like,
you know where you can get this nitrous
oxide dude,
I have no idea,
but if you get it from dunkins testicles
that lets it out and whistles.
Like I heard of a chicken Jersey one
time while he was in the hospital,
some chick came in,
she put a frozen a hotdog and they'll
push it up broke so she had to go get
it.
Oh,
she was so cold,
like a fucking ballpark.
She's such a bitch.
That shit didn't even fuck up.
Go fuck him.
Crushed it came out the snow
icicle.
I mean if you can think of it,
someone stuffed it up there.
I just call a dude,
right?
Someone is someone stuffed ticket name
for a kid's book.
These microphones stands.
Someone's shoved up their ass,
right?
Someone's shoved beer bottles up the
Ras.
We've also two guys,
one cup or see that the guy stuck or
gummies.
Jara possess.
You just see that.
Oh,
he pushed.
Stuck like a,
like a,
like one of those jars.
We get some really good jelly,
you know,
you get that preserved.
Whereas like a fancy fancy glass jar
like I had that deepen his ass and it
broke and then clunks have chunks of
broken glass and blood or coming out of
his ass.
I mean it is a crazy fucking.
See what about those junkies in prison?
They walk around with a syringe in
there,
a fucking syringe with a spoon batches
and want they tuck
it in their asshole store syringes.
In your end,
after 10 years of doing it,
it just like nothing open your ass old
tickets needle out of that.
Oh my God.
It's not the way they say that.
A lot of guys get hepatitis from
exchanging needles if they don't have
clean needles.
It's fucked up though.
There's diseases that come just from
sex,
like how did syphilis ever get,
you know,
we know we were talking about like swine
flu and all these different things that
come from from massive farms,
which is a lot.
A lot of fluids come from fucking
sexually transmitted diseases come from
who?
Who's the first person to get herpes?
Like how did,
how did that get Kelly cursed
syphilis,
syphilis.
Now what is syphilis?
How does it get into what comes out of
your Dick?
What comes up?
What leakage?
When I was about 15,
my buddy told me I had a problem.
He goes,
can you go to the clinic with me?
Hello Boo.
Forget going to the clinic afterschool.
Not even thinking about it guys and see
them bitches with sores in their mouth
and fucking shit leak.
And I was like,
I made a mental note right there,
like right there.
I was like,
I ain't fucking around with bitches til
I'm older.
Well,
this is the.
One of the things that they,
they shut down the porn industry because
the dude syphilis and started giving
the.
Yeah,
this is a during 2010,
there was for 45,834
new cases of syphilis compared to
48,000.
Um,
uh,
HIV infections and 300,
9,000
cases of gonorrhea.
Whoa.
Gary is popular.
Which ones?
Three hundred and 9,000
cases of gonorrhea.
That's just for those who thought
gonorrhea was over his backyard.
They got a rear coming on.
It's Kinda read the class.
I took a question.
Is that the clap?
Gonorrhea as the class,
I would assume it was that
two thirds of a syphilis occurred
amongst men who have sex with men.
Wow.
Most syphilis is gay syphilis.
Interesting.
There are 377 reports of children with
congenital syphilis.
Which means town with it.
Yeah.
Syphilis.
The transmitted from person to person.
It's a bacterium.
Disease caused by long.
It's caused by bacterium can cause
longterm complications and slash or
death not adequately treated.
Sores can occur on the lips and in the
mouth.
Syphilis can be transmitted during
vaginal,
anal,
or oral.
Sexual contact.
Pregnant women with the disease can pass
it onto their unborn children.
Whoa.
Damn you.
Syphilis.
Syphilis is a motherfucker.
How quickly the symptoms appear after
infection.
The average time between infection and
with syphilis and the appearance of the
first symptom is 21 days,
but it can range up to 90 days.
Woo
did.
I knew a guy who used to say that
fucking pussy with was the best
pussy.
That is crazy because it was so hot
because it was like feverish,
feverish hot.
Oh my God.
I think it's safe to say that guys.
Silly Bitch.
How many times has he done it?
That's crazy.
Oh Man.
I forgot to read the fucking male whores
all looking for bitch with gonorrhea.
First of all.
I did not.
I'm not here for a long time.
I did not say it like that.
That's number one.
Get someone that lava pushing.
He's been live at
multiple posts.
If motherfuckers that love period pussy
you know to do,
I can't even look at that fucking dragon
when there's bloody track and well,
when I was like,
well,
after my mother died I got a call from
some checkout,
a bike,
like she called me up when the note was
still living in the house.
Like I was still living in the fucking
house.
I would walk to a house because in those
days you had no fucking text or nothing.
You got to dial that long.
Motherfucking number two.
You had to go deep on your fucking phone
and walk over,
walk but bitch back.
Remember when to check lyft and another
part of the distance and long distance
and you couldn't fall in love.
There was no skype.
You had a whack off on the phone that
costs you $10 to wipe off.
Remember sports phone?
No body.
What is that?
Sports phone.
Where's your phone for the general
gamblers that cost you thirty five cents
to call.
They updated every 30 minutes though.
Oh,
you remember that?
That was the only thing.
The only time outside of sex calls.
That's it,
but this is back in the eighties man bar
shooting pool and the motherfucker come
and go with one of the knick game.
I don't know,
course sports phone.
I call the second phone line once while
I was beating off and I was a kid and
and,
and pain.
When the chick asked me,
can I help you?
Can I help you?
I was like,
Oh yeah.
what am I going to do?
How am I going to pay for this?
I don't have a credit card,
but I just just all over myself.
So that's all you need.
Sometimes just the voice.
He's like,
oh,
you're back.
How much?
I mean that's probably how many dudes
probably called people up.
Remember how far they were on the phone.
I remember it being a security guard at
night at this complex they were building
for seniors and the only thing to do was
like you bought at night,
you just call the phone.
So I used to go down to the party line,
like I ran up like a thousand dollar
bill in like a week.
So I'm a security guard and I got to pay
this shit back then taking the money out
of my check.
I'm basically working for this party
line.
It was just crazy.
Wow.
That's one of those.
What happens on a party line.
He just talked to a bunch of people.
That's incredible.
It's almost like it's the chat phone.
Internet.
Yeah.
It's like,
yeah,
chat roulette now basically.
But how many people were in the room
with you when you would call?
You called the number you talked to like
three or four people in.
Some people just listen.
Some people contribute.
Some people will get off the people that
joined on and never called the party
line.
No,
I never called.
It was.
It was addictive until I got that bill.
Then I was like,
shit was expensive.
Yo.
That's isn't that amazing
that they could just charge you to
connect your fucking phone lines
together and charge you ridiculous
amounts of money and you don't even know
what you.
It's not like you see it like running
like a meter.
So you can go,
ah,
just hang it up.
Those lines.
Sometimes there'll be girls.
No,
but you can't see them.
You know,
it was just talking.
Are they from your town?
No idea.
It was like,
I don't know if it was an 800 number or
some shit like that.
I bet a lot of people probably
pretending they were from your town way
from Kansas.
I'm from Kansas to get you coming to get
you.
I'm coming to get you out.
I'm on my way.
I saw a show about a guy who got tricked
by these Nigerian scammers and it was
fucking sad.
This poor dude went to Europe twice.
He believed that this girl was waiting
for them in Europe twice.
See that kind of creepy ass fucked up.
Yeah.
It's like,
what the fuck,
man?
He got went there twice.
Loneliness sucks.
Sucks hard,
but that's how social media works on a
computer.
It's just from back in the day when we
used to make those phone calls to those
party lines.
People just been lonely for ages.
It's just a way to connect without being
in front of somebody and then that's why
facebook and my space is so successful
for was well,
people literally get sick when they
don't have contact with other people
that if they don't get sick physically,
they get sick mentally.
Something something goes wrong.
You will go to a strip club and you can
tell the dudes that are fucking lonely
bro.
They bring the chicks gifts.
Oh yeah.
How's your brother?
Yeah,
let's do a dance.
I really don't want to dance for you.
You see those guys and if you interview
a stripper stripper,
and she started to tell you those
stories,
your heartbreaks and like really sweet
guy came in and gave me $800.
Sit and talk to you for now.
Well,
when I used to go to visit Eddie,
when Eddie worked as a DJ,
you know,
I got to watch some really crazy shit.
She got to see the girls were just like,
you know,
they'd be like your friend,
like,
Hey,
what's up?
how you doing?
You know,
like Eddie was like,
just like friends with all these girls,
they would come in and then guys would
like buy them cars and this one girl,
the guy came in and she immediately was
like,
oh my God,
how are you?
She puts on this act and goes runs over
and hugs him and she's like,
she's really hot and she's naked.
Okay.
She's really hot and she's naked and the
dude is a zero,
you know?
He's a Dorky,
sad,
goofy,
confused guy who's just not that good
socially and doesn't understand is being
played.
And I think he had like a regular job
too,
man.
It was like a fucking postman or some
shit,
but he would blow all his money on her
and he got her car,
like at least they're like one of those
Nice Yukon's.
So like it was crazy,
but they just take them like a vampire
as fuck.
Just draw them in and just,
just for the guy,
just to be in contact with the girl like
that is enough to chicks.
The guys that give them the most are the
ones that don't push.
They don't want to
listen.
When I kidnapped that dude partner,
my partner and my partner on the deal,
the reason it's motivation,
like you know when you go to acting
class and they're like,
what's your motivation?
Is Motivation for the kidnapping?
Was he was dating the chick?
No,
no,
no.
He was friends with a chicken strip club
that danced naked.
Her and her husband had a beef.
He threw her out.
She loved the guy,
you know the guy,
but she wouldn't sleep with him because
she was Catholic.
She couldn't sleep with until she got
divorced.
This guy was giving her all his.
It's the guys that don't get the pussy
that give the most.
Yeah.
It's a story as old as time.
It's fucking amazing.
I want to be into the stripper part of
the story,
but when you say the time I kidnapped
that dude,
I just can't.
I can't just,
I don't know the stories.
I can't just disgusts me that,
uh,
that I saw that when he told me he came
to my house,
they looked at mine.
It's like,
oh,
we got kidnapped.
Or at that time it wasn't a kidnapping.
He's like,
we got to rob this dude,
I need the money.
I'm like,
well,
he told me the story and I'm like,
oh,
did you have like red flags going off?
Like,
it wasn't even Robert and for the good
of it,
you know,
he was robbing for a check so she could
get divorced.
Oh,
oh,
here's where it gets better.
He owns the house.
His mother had a bunch of houses.
She was a real estate mogul.
He fucking had her.
And one of the House was Doug Benson
Lynch gentlemen.
He had,
um,
one of the houses,
free rent.
He was paying the rent for it.
That's so common.
It's just girls in this powerful.
Doug Benson said,
buddy,
it's very fucking girls have been doing
that forever.
But guys been doing that.
The girls too,
man.
It's like people get played.
I think if you want to be a victim,
some guys want to say,
I want a girl in a car.
Nothing happened.
Well,
it's also that these guys are so that
the girls are so out of their league
that they're willing to do.
Almost anything to get in.
They can't believe these girls or even
talking to them.
I mean girls are tendons,
man,
incredible body,
beautiful.
Look at that ass.
I can't believe she's sitting on my lap
and she's stroking his hair and puts her
tits in his face and juggles and back
and forth,
and this dude is gone,
man.
He's in heaven.
This is.
This is closer to heaven than he's ever
been because no girl would ever looked
at anything like this has ever touched
them and no girls ever really wanted to
touch them.
Some dudes that go through life without
anybody being like really passionate
about them ever.
No one's attracted to them.
They they're socially awkward.
Who knows what kind of fucking weird
childhood they had and this girls can do
a number on a dude like that.
Hey man,
there's no way she could.
There's no way could stop her.
Especially when know chicks sitting on
their lap and they like seeing chicks
like this.
Sit On dudes.
A lapse in movies and it's like you're
just living in the movie lifestyle just
for a moment and you'll pay for any.
Can't believe.
It's ready.
You believe there's trained agents who
are like chicks
in the CIA or trained to get fucked to
like set people up on our 100 percent.
They've done that.
Yeah.
One hundred percent.
They've gotten people to the point where
they were were undercover and they had
to have sex with people unquestionably,
but they.
Do you think they train them?
Do you think there's like a show to a
training center for hot girls want to
listen.
If you're going to fuck this guy,
you can't fuck them like an agent.
Okay.
You gotta fuck.
I'm like,
you're crazy bitch.
And your cock monster.
You've got to learn how to study these
videos.
This is a girl named Amber Lynn in the
eighties.
She was a monster.
Just a cock monster.
I know this dude that runs like charm
school,
right?
So he works with the federal government.
The FBI like to teach the agents how to
not get seduced by women.
Really?
Yeah.
So that's what you're saying is,
is real.
So that's probably right because it's a
powerful weapon.
I mean you can.
If you really want to take down that at
present,
you can take down anybody with a body
with a woman.
Yeah.
Sex is.
It's so powerful to someone who can
acquire it.
It's like one of the most sweetest
nectar known.
Well,
if you can acquire it on a regular
basis,
it loses its power,
but it's just like getting your heroin
fix everyday.
They're like,
yeah,
and then nothing.
It's just fucking heroin.
There's a lot of functional heroin users
who's a lot of functional sex addicts.
You know when you're involved with that
type of a crime.
That's why I always laugh when I read
about drug bust or something because the
general public doesn't know when you
have that.
When somebody is selling 80 kilos a
fucking month,
guess what?
That'll make that many mistakes.
Right?
For an agent to infiltrate them,
they have to do something different.
Yeah,
like when I was locked up in the federal
joint for a couple months,
I got to meet people,
told me stories about shoot the fucking
blow with agents says that the agents
crossed the line.
The agents got got out.
They go to trial.
They go to rehab and they get there.
Then they don't have in their system,
so I'm in court yelling,
I got high with Duncan.
You're like,
that was a year ago.
Prove it,
prove it,
but it's amazing.
You know?
That's why you know I'm going to sell a
kilo of coke to a guy who doesn't do
copeland.
I don't do it.
I'm a business.
That's the weird fucking thing,
man.
Really weird thing,
Where the cop is CIA agent or whoever it
is begins to turn into the thing that
they're hunting begins to like get
sucked into that and then there are the
criminal shit.
You have to.
There's no way looking when you go talk
to attorneys,
if you ever get in trouble when you go
talk to attorneys,
you can talk to.
These dudes are very booksmart.
The attorney you want is the guy that
knows his way around the court system.
The Guy who went to college with a judge
who's going to cut a deal,
he went to school with the district
attorney.
You follow me?
You got these guys are very book.
Yeah.
They know the fucking long litigation
that goes so far.
It's the motherfuckers that could cut a
deal to have.
The same thing applies with cops.
If you're going to bust a,
you got to become a criminal.
You gotta think like him.
That's why these guys,
they show you all straight laced.
That's bullshit.
You got to think like them.
There's no way a guy.
There's no way a guy that looks like a.
whatever's you went,
Solomon,
solemn of mushrooms,
you following these have to look like
fucking Charles Manson.
He's gonna.
Have to eat a cup of mushrooms in front
of you.
Then you'll get them announce there's no
way.
It's common.
Fucking how many times have agents had
to do asset in front of people?
Just fucking gas.
Tons of it all,
but that's how the FBI does its local
fucking county.
Listen to have county sheriff under
coverage.
Those are the filthiest from the covers
there.
Vice of the filthiest under the covers
there and once you hang somewhere,
you see them come in and see.
When that was a boulder,
I worked at the patrol car wash,
so they had a contract with the town.
They would all come in.
They would just go around with
confiscated cars.
Sure.
If you're a cop in boulder,
if you're a competent boulder sheriff
department,
you don't arrest people in Boulder.
You go to the mountains and the
undercovers in the mountains come down
to boulder,
so you're taking.
Let's say I confiscate Joe Rogan's,
bad ass car.
I'm not going to drive around boulder.
That's dumb.
People going to to Joe Rogan's car.
No,
I take that same car and I go to fucking
Colorado Springs and I become a cop and
that's how they do it.
They don't take your stuff and used in
the same county.
I became friends with those guys.
Those county guys had beards.
They wreak the booze.
They were out every night.
It's weird that they can confiscate your
shit and confiscate your shadow.
I watched a,
a,
an episode of top gear and the American
version,
when they confiscated a corvette,
zero six and they turned it into a cop
car dealer.
You're in jail watching TV going.
That's my guts,
your fucking car.
It's amazing about this deficit that we
have because if they confiscate all this
fucking blow in cash every year.
What the fuck does it go?
Are you from Grove County Dunk?
Uh,
uh.
Yo,
Tarzan.
You from Grove,
Columbus,
Grove county high school or something.
You know what that is in Columbus.
Worthington.
What were you doing with grover's and
Columbus Grove or something?
I just walk around the city.
Grow city.
Let me tell you how bad a shape Columbus
Ohio was in grove city to play high
school football.
You gotta pay $150 a semester as fucking
parent for your son to play in a public
school dog.
They had to cancel the program.
The band of Grove city is one of the top
five high school bands in the country
don't exist.
No more lonely.
She wanted to talk to me about sending
motherfuckers to Mazda Shit again.
You have to pay high school now for your
kids to and it's going to be a growing
thing across the country because of the
fucking school budgets that if your
parents.
What you want to play in high school
sports now by the year 2015,
you're going to have to pay for your son
to play high school fucking sport,
my friend.
So put that in your pipe and smoke it
the time tonight with magic.
If you go home and watch real sports,
they did a pretty nice thing.
I magic motherfucking Johnson.
They
said that's the cover.
He went from dead man to a fucking
gazillionaire.
He went from a fucking dead man to be in
the fucking gazillionaire.
So Watch we'll sports on HBO.
They always do beautiful fucking things.
That shit.
Pay One hundred 50 each parent for each
kid.
Kids you know,
you know brother,
inner city.
It's ridiculous.
When you think about how much money gets
spent on other shit,
bitch,
you know there's a six point $8.
Billion dollars is what we spend a month
in Afghanistan,
six point 8 billion.
They could spend six point
$8,000,000,000.
The the astrophysicist Neil degrasse
Tyson said that they could come up with
some incredible,
a webspace telegraph telescope.
The government pulled the plug on it
because they didn't have the money.
They'd have the money to discover new
planets and possibly search for life or
figure out what got us here,
what could prevent the demise of the
world.
Instead,
they got all this money for Afghanistan.
We still in Afghanistan.
Anyway,
we got bin Ladin.
Well,
if he talked to the really crazy people,
they say heroin.
Heroin.
Yeah.
They say heroin.
The really a crazy conspiracy theory
guys.
They say that it's all a big heroin
operation.
Well,
yeah,
because like if you want to fund black
operations,
you do it with drug sales because it's
untraceable.
So if the CIO wants to do completely
untraceable operations,
they just blow.
They confiscated.
Or when we had guys on from vice
vice.com,
they.
They were just saying that essentially
there's no other way it could be
happening because 90 plus percent of the
world's opium and heroin comes from
Afghanistan and we're in control of that
area and there's video footage of
soldiers that are actually like guarding
the fucking poppy fields.
It's craziness.
It's like you look at it and you go,
this bizarre shit.
How has this on television?
How is this real?
It's all the shit that people in
conspiracy theory chat rooms had been
saying forever and what's oxicon
synthetic heroin when you got all these
pills that will lose their minds over
heroin,
not dimension.
How much about fucking profit?
I invest $50,000
a pound.
The heroin,
I could chop that motherfucker,
don't make me make my profit 10 times.
I could walk out of there with $450,000
on a fucking kilo of heroin right now if
they could ever really proved that the
government has always been selling
heroin place.
That would be.
That would be insane times if you really
found that out.
I mean,
when you say the government though,
and it's like it's not really.
They're all different branches and shit.
It's like you can't really blame the FBI
if some dea guys are selling heroin,
you know,
you can't blame the NSA.
The CIA is doing something because it's
kind of all different organizations.
But if we found out that one of them was
actually long term selling heroin,
if you watch,
let's say you also the movie American
gangster,
how the fuck does a black guy from
Harlem?
Hey Man,
I'm
just because you're black.
I know what I'm saying.
This is your shift or black guy.
A black dude ends up.
You know,
it's funny.
It's like it's such a proud moment in
black history that you got to fight for
the negativity.
No,
he did that shit.
Fuck that Joey.
A black man.
Black.
Nothing.
There's nothing.
How does a black ended up in fucking
Vietnam?
Copland.
Heroin guys.
Yeah.
You think that gate and that thing was
just made for him.
He had helped me that that was something
somebody comes up and goes,
hey,
sure,
fuck the guineas.
I know what he gets for sure.
We're going to take you to Thailand.
Thailand.
Yeah.
Let's go to the fucking time.
Not only just the Thailand into the
city,
but until the jungles when they fucking
process and you got to do a white dude.
Black Dude is going to go in there just
like that.
That's what you're trying to tell me and
come back and go in with $200,
million cash.
That's what you're trying to tell me.
So he did that alone just.
And I'm not taking away to nothing from
no black dude.
I'm just saying.
I'm just saying that,
you know,
first of all there's no winning this
fight for this.
His brother wouldn't go nowhere with two
of the Gita.
He got 200 g's.
I ain't got nowhere to go,
Doug.
You know what I'm saying?
I'll sit here to this 200 to $200
million.
Whatever the fuck he took over the wild
way to live your life,
man.
A lot of people don't believe that story
anyway,
now they don't really in it like in
Harlem.
Oh really?
What I'm saying?
He's saying Frank Lucas didn't do that.
And,
and they just,
they just say he was a chauffeur.
You know,
that there's people that downplaying,
oh,
he's a chauffeur.
He didn't do that.
It's just,
you know,
there was three and two of those
motherfuckers.
There was two or three,
those motherfuckers that Ran Harlem in
the fifties and sixties and all they
were with the same thing as my father.
My real father came from Cuba.
They needed a fucking face to go in
there.
Know fucking Cuban's ain't going to buy
from no Jew and the fucking guineas
aren't gonna.
I ain't going to buy from know Italians.
So they took this fucking.
They took a couple of black guys and
they made him.
They said,
listen,
we'll cut 30 percent,
30 percent of $500,000
profit.
That's a lot of fucking money when you
live on the fifth floor of the fucking
building dog.
That's $150,000
a month times three or four.
So they became a pipelines to the black
community.
Don't fucking.
There was no,
there was no genius there.
The guineas came to them.
They cut it 50 fucking times and they
gave it to the brothers and the brothers
got it.
Then they fucking sold it.
And if you go to,
if you went to New York and you grew up
in how many motherfuckers you see,
not the light.
Listen,
that's why,
that's why I buy my coke from white
people.
My shit up in Edward's comment on
twitter.
You dirty bitches.
Follow him.
Follow Duncan trussell on twitter.
We are U s s e l you got to end this.
This been going on for three hours.
Oh Shit.
Joe Diaz is on twitter.
Fucking mad flavor,
mad flavor,
mad flavor a thank you to.
Thanks for sponsoring this podcast.
And if you go to [inaudible] dot ting
dot,
you can sign up and save 50 bucks off of
any of the smartphones they have
available.
It's an awesome service.
You don't have to have contracts,
you can cancel them anytime you want and
you still walk away a bad motherfucker.
You your money's safer with them.
It rolls over if you like.
Don't use your minutes.
It rolls over into the next month.
You can have multiple people.
Yeah,
they have a lot of good deal.
Had a rollover that's even better.
Yeah,
and they also have like say if you and I
had two lines,
we can put them on one account and we
could split the numbers like say if you
have a family and you want to get a
phone for your wife or your girlfriend
or whatever,
or some sun that won't leave your
fucking house and you've got to pay for
this little fucking puke.
Get them a phone.
She lost a lot of ambition,
lost a lot of energy in this room,
feel it,
says Joe Diaz walked out and it was just
a fucking vacuum.
Chose the love with us and thanks to
[inaudible] dot com for sponsoring us.
Go to o,
n n I t use a codename Rogan and you
will save 10 percent off any and all
supplements and thank you to everybody
who comes to these shows and everybody
who came this weekend in North Carolina.
Duncan and I had a great fucking time.
Thank you very much.
That shit was magical,
right there were amazing.
I'm a desk [inaudible] dot TV.
Go Get yourself some kitty cat shirts by
the great brian red band.
Come see me and Brendan and Tony in
Columbus,
Ohio,
November 10th,
folks at the woodlands tavern,
so go and check that out and if you've
never seen Brendan Walsh,
he's fucking brilliant comedian.
Very,
very funny guy and of course Brian is
silly bitch and very funny on stage as
well.
And Tony Hinchcliffe is a up and comer.
Very funny kid.
He's really good writer.
I really,
really,
really liked that kid.
He's actually opening up for Jeff Garlin
right now.
Bam Son.
See what I said.
Don't fucking doubt me.
Goddammit.
Doug Benson is in the house.
Ladies and gentlemen,
even though he didn't talk.
Powerful.
Doug Benson,
nothing says thanks for being here
budding.
Just saying,
hi man.
I'm just letting the folks know that
you're here.
You affected this room with your mere
presence desk,
squad,
dot TV.
Go get yourself some cats,
cat tee shirts.
Get yourself also recognize where the
shows are taking place and you can find
out about ice house shows and all that
good stuff and we have shows here pretty
regularly.
We're going to do.
I'm like,
Bob,
the owner of the Ice House asked me to
do shows here on a regular basis on
Wednesdays.
So that's what we're going to try to do.
So,
uh,
that's it.
You fucking freaks.
We'll see you tomorrow with Amber Lyon
and Brian Windows.
Uh,
Kevin Pereira.
Start noon
tomorrow.
And we actually have semen on,
on tomorrow.
Beautiful Room talking about the in the.
Oh,
that's going to be less tense.
Intense,
straight outta compton.
Nwa,
you know,
we say thanks all the time folks,
but we can't say it enough.
Uh,
this,
uh,
this has been a very strange ride these
last,
especially this last year or so of this
podcast.
It's a very strange experience and don't
think that we ever take it for granted.
But Duncan
and I talk about it on the phone all the
time.
We're always constantly laughing about
it.
Brian and I talked about we all.
This is a weird time for all of us,
but we appreciate the fuck out of all of
it.
And all these people that come to these
shows,
the enthusiasm,
the positivity,
the friendliness,
just we were blessed.
We're just lucky as fuck and we're not
stopping.
We're going to keep doing this.
Don't ever worry.
We're not going away.
It's going to.
We're going to move forward.
Press on getting bigger and better and
introduce more cool motherfuckers to you
like Ian Edwards.
Ladies and gentlemen.
All right,
you fucking freaks.
We'll see you tomorrow.